uni etats unis arménie donc c'est parti
en fait j'ai voulu lancer le live à 19h
pile je me suis donc j'aurai large il va
y avoir une présentation un machin puis
ce match commencera à 19h15 ou quoi et
je me suis fait dribbler donc on a raté
les quelques premières secondes les 30
premières secondes du match
bon après ça va c'est pas c'est pas le
truc le plus grave est quand même
et quand même mais quand même à signaler
ça a commencé pile à l'heure pour la
finale c'est devez linverse des autres
jours en fait ce que marrant ce qui est
marrant donc bas les joueurs vous les
connaissez ils sont ils sont en dessous
du cours en profitait pour pour
représenter les hommes je vais mettre un
peu plus grand jeu un peu me cacher pour
que tout le monde voit bien même sur un
mobile et on refera après le le visuel
correct donc premier échiquier pour les
100 new york bishop fabiano caruana
est-ce qu'il a présentée non il a été
vice-champion du monde en quelque sorte
numéro deux mondial et vice champion du
monde puisqu'il a perdu le match contre
magnus carlsen il ya maintenant deux ans
de ça et donc il sera aux premières
équipes y est côté saint louis on va
présenter le premier chic arménien en
face du coup par à maxou de l'oudon plus
a été champion du monde juniors il ya
peut-être deux trois ans de ça et il est
2700 villes aux alentours de 1700 quoi
il navigue entre 26 90 et 27 10 je crois
à peu près deuxième échiquier liner
dominguez alors c'est le second dans de
fabiano caruana il est devenu américain
c'est un joueur cubain et il est monté
il est monté dans le top 10 mondial sur
un gros rush n'y a pas si longtemps de
ça et je crois qu'il est redescendu vers
la 13e 14e place mondiale donc très très
très gros joueurs en face de lui avec
martirossian deuxième et chic arménien
donc ike gros joueurs avec un x sur
internet
très connu il a été je pense champion du
monde moins de 12 ans moins de 14 ans
peut-être tout cas dans les petites
catégories c'est un joueur qui a été un
jeune joueur très dangereux
là maintenant il a une vingtaine
d'années il est spécialiste du blitz sur
internet en réalité du rapide sur
internet donc joueur très dangereux avec
qui pâtit peut-être à qui pâtit
peut-être pas je cherche mais qui pâtit
peut-être mais je ne sais pas j'ai pas
le mot les gars qui peut être pas pâti
peut-être de la mauvaise réputation des
arméniens à tort voilà j'ai la phrase
fatigue peut-être de la mauvaise
réputation des arméniens à tort ike
parce que c'est un gros joueur et
honnêtement dans ces arméniens qui ont
des grosses performances sur le net
c'est celui sur lequel moi à titre
personnel j'ai le plus de doutes mais
dans le sens positif et en me disant
peut-être lui peut le faire parce que je
crois qu'il a le profil de joueur hyper
doué qui aime bien blitz et qu'un
excellent beats heures et qui n'aime pas
trop les parties longues donc qui sait
ces résultats sont sont peut-être
légitime ah parce que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de doutes sur tous ses joueurs
à meinier en général on va on va parler
sérieusement mais avec la pour la peine
je dirais que
pour aller à l'encontre de ces deux ses
détracteurs et sens et sans second degré
ou quoique il a peut-être les capacités
en blitz eu des résultats qu'ils
réalisent 3d mais chic et wesley so donc
pour les saint-louis arc bishop wesley
so baisse qui l'a présenté joueur très
solide du top mondial il a été pendant
longtemps dans le top 10 mondial joue
pas actuellement si les numéros 9 10 11
c'est pas la question c'est un gros
membre du top top 10 15 donc énorme
joueur wesley so il n'est pas présentée
en face à tigran petrosyan qui est un
bon joueur bon blitzer 2006 à et
quelques assureurs sur en feed et gros
joueurs surtout chasse comme au
quatrième échiquier jefferies xiong donc
c'est le numéro 2 - de 21 en lots il
doit voir 27 22 il a un talent de ouf et
c'est un énorme joueur aussi un c'est
peut-être le prochaine américain à
rentrer dans le top 10 même si je le
vois pas devenir un mode du top 5
mondial à long terme mais mais mais il
peut vraiment réussir à faire un rush
pour faire top 20 top 10 mondial c'est
un gros joueur est en face de lui renac
ça doit ni qui est un des grands espoirs
aussi indiens je repars avec mathieu
tout à l'heure au téléphone leur maître
cornette
il m'impressionne pas comme mathieu ils
ne m'impressionnent joueurs qui ne
m'impressionne pas d'art comme je dis je
les jouais et et j'ai réussi à faire
annuler donc c'est pour vous dire à quel
point ils m'impressionnent pas en
passant par une position gagnante ce
temps au protoss ligue aussi en rapide
mais il a des résultats de ouf
il a eu des excellents résultats je me
rappelle à l'open de l'île de man ya
qu'il ya un an de ça où il avait fait il
enchaîné nul sur nul contre des joueurs
à 2700 plus blanc pro-chasse ighil a
battu guiry il a fait un énorme match en
demi finale donc c'est un jeune
mais voilà ce style de jeu
m'impressionne pas le joueur
m'impressionne pas mais il a les
résultats et il est aux alentours de
2500 mais il est âgé que de 14 ans il
était en grosse phase de progression
avant de confinement donc il est encore
en train de progresser il joue peut-être
à 25 50 26 déjà c'est très possible et
il a surpris et il a surpris en demi
finale donc écouter on va avoir en tout
cas les joueurs sont présentés le match
est lancé alors on va se regarder cette
première petite position premiers
échiquiers aulas vous voyez aussi la
différence et lokua premier échiquier
arménien donc par am maxou blue qui est
26 74 contre direction qui est 27-12 on
sert que le moins fort joueur américain
est sur le papier plus fort que le
meilleur arménien c'est pour vous dire
la différence de niveau est ici dans
cette position alors qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que ça donne j'en sais rien je
vais boire un peu de thé du coup dans
quelle structure de type française
enfin c'est une catalane mais ça peut
donner un truc un peu cheap française si
elle pion aux trois un peu dans ce même
esprit du x 6 mal placé mais bon c'est
une structure les catalanes
le fou g2 qui va cracher du feu sur ds3
mais le fois ci ce qui va aider à gagner
la case d3 ces genres une position très
typique de ces catalan ya eu la belle
poussée halal dame qui a été réalisée
position incertaine un cessez pas clair
on va regarder ou est ce les sauts aux
deux contres ike bat normalement ils
vont souffrir quand même de partout les
arméniens il n'y a que des y'a que des
monstres en face cette position alors
elle donne quoi il ya le fameux débat
des des berlinois des antilles
berlinoise là pour la peine avec avec la
laprise ans et 6 mai c'est le même débat
que dans toutes ces français espagnol
des changes à savoir est ce que la paire
de fouet supérieur aux problèmes
structurels qui donc est ce que le
problème structurel est plus grave que
le que la présence de la paire de fous
où est ce que les blancs finalement leur
bonne structure va plus leur servir ici
ça sent quand même être petite pression
pour les blancs cavaliers à 5 est très
bien placé et sur un coup comme b6 des
cavaliers ces six vont pouvoir arriver
est ce qu'en fouillant 17 sur des cas il
prend 1,5 donc est donc ce cas il sera
dur à à chasser de ses 6 on va aller
voir tigran petrosyan contre les
meilleurs dominguez alors là j'aime bien
la position de petrosyan pour du blitz
en tout cas alors ok il ya pioncer 2 qui
est sous pression mais un plan simple
comme enfin simple comme f4 ou f3 food
et un damage de roy g2 d'un match retour
h1
alors ça prend quoi ça fait 1 2 3 4 5 et
tu es tu es tu va choper h7 et g7 en
face il va falloir trouver une manière
d'attaquer ou des plans les joueurs
doivent être en train de calculer ça
mais c'est genre de positions assez
agréable à jouer en rapide parce que ça
va vite et il ya un plan clair net et
précis
on peut aussi jouer avec fois h3 damage
de essayer de voilà on peut le faire
différemment on peut faire aussi du
fouet trois tours deux tours age 2 rois
j'ai deux tours h1 à aimer le ranger de
sera mal placé
le truc c'est pourquoi je dis ça parce
qu'en fait quand on met le roi en g2
pourquoi je mets le fou en d1 pour pas
perdre ses deux donc avoir mon positions
complexes et fabiano caruana contre
rhône axa doany ou là alors là c'est une
sicilienne time and offs et les
positions que je joue mal je me suis
beaucoup mais stream vous devez le
savoir ça j pige pas grand chose mais il
ya un truc que je sais c'est que quand
tu as le fou qui est venu en c5 que tu
as l'autre en bessette sur le roi est
allé colonnes qui vont s'ouvrir un petit
peu ici ça m'a l'air d'être un peu
kathak pour ça doit ni qui a pas réussi
à assécher la position après j'avais dit
j'avais dit que ça douaniers étaient
très mal contre gries tchouk et il avait
sauvé dans une finale technique en plus
ce qui était une belle prouesse bon ici
ça me paraît vraiment dur mais encore un
avantage c'est que ça peut vite tourner
genre si tu fais grand roque on va pour
prendre le cavalier e 5 à y aura sur
angers 5 mai au caire
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que la
position est très compliqué elle est
difficile pour les deux joueurs en fait
juste ça fait peur en sortant
l'ouverture 10 adouani tu vas caruana de
l'autre côté de l'échiquier et tu vois
une position quand même assez assez
complexe on s'envoie de partout il fait
5 ans premier à cavayé qui rend 34 il va
faire j'ai h ça va échanger à peut-être
le faire ghf 5 pour ça
ça s'est un peu est intéressant pour les
noirs et il prend tous les rebonds vers
des six je fais le chemin du cavalier à
l'envers ça peut servir
mais bon il y aura toujours à des uns et
le pro
mc cash 5 pieds en l'air pour faire rock
on va peut-être jouer soirée autour des
8 soit avec g 6 mai ouais bah ce fou de
kazan me paraît fort quand même un jour
il peut aller pub l'échoppé les pions
c'est compliqué les gars donc élu
cavalli proches 4 ça c'est la partie
vraiment compliqué on va retourner côté
hawks gong exemple j'aime bien sa
position parce que foot et quatre devant
le pion des cinq dans quelques paris qui
le fou a le x 6 on voit pas trop jouer
et le fou des quatre on voit qu'un jour
il s'ouvre après des six la vraie finale
en fait c'était panda contre harper
bishop il semblerait du luxe étaient les
deux gros favorite d'ailleurs les pandas
ont battu assez facilement les trois
bras on va faire un petit tour mais bon
va voir par le truc c'est cette position
il me semble vraiment bien aller pour
les blancs d'ailleurs il a fait foi h3
f5 qui était un autre plan que fin il a
fait f5 il a fait 5 pardon ah oui pour
jouer sur puis on prend fou prend des
cinq ans s était pas con
ah oui là il peut y avoir des dommages
cinq dames sept cavaliers ces cinq cas
une proposition nul on va essayer de la
trouver sélection qui propose nul ici
c'est étonnant parce qu'il a quand même
le fou des cats a quand même le cavalier
ou quatre sous pression alors après
c'est peut-être qui se dit va faire
fougue et c'est terrible inde mais
j'avais quand même l'impression que
c'est un peu les blancs qui pressait il
ya eu des positions de possibilités de
fou mais ici ça vous prend à 5 1 jour ok
c'est intéressant ça pour pour les
arméniens je pense que par am doit la
prendre en tout cas y réfléchit
d'accord alors dans la partie ça roanne
il y des failles et eu l'avant dont je
vous ai parlé c'est pour ça que je
reviens pas sur les coûts et l'idée
c'est qu'à rédiger un f3 g5
il doit pouvoir la tenir ça doit ni et
ça va leur faire un bon résultat un nul
contre donc nuls 1-1 à partie deux
paragraphes de parham du coup avec le
pop art amorphe
si ça doit ni la tiens c'est plutôt
bonne opération puisque quand vous
regardez en bas en fait ça veut dire
qu'ils auraient annulé caruana ça doit
ni et xing maqsoud ou du coup les uns et
les quatre c'est peut-être là ils sont
contents d'annuler 1 et 4 passes que 2
et 3 c'est les deux joueurs arménien et
là ils ont ils à il a quand même une
super position
petrossian regardez juste comparer les
fous de cases blanches
en réalité c'est simple là il ya des
bandes genre çà çà çà çà et damas est
je veux rentrer henry vii les gars donc
on va dire qu'on joue tour à tour et
fuite on va on va jouer logique
dams est prise afin prise f1 et regarder
la dame peut rentrer et sur dams et 6
jets à minima un échec et j'encaisse bon
c'est des petites variantes un ca veut
pas forcément dire que ça va être la
partie mais c'est pour illustrer abbas
et la partie justement et damas est
damas est ça fait mal puisque tu rentres
dans la position adverse
et ça va gagner ça peut gagner ça peut
gagner nous ça peut faire un point pour
les arméniens sadoine is ses shows
soarès au sens n'est pas revenu depuis
un moment où là elle est dure la finale
oulala oulala elle est dure elle est
dure elle est dure parce que y'a roi des
trois c4 qui rentrent éventuellement et
ya la majorité âgés 3 et 4 qui rentre au
centre donc on va dire qu'il ya une
belle balle côté arménien avec
petrossian il ya une belle balle côtes
américains avec sow et il ya une patate
chaude
côté ça doit ni parce que quand même
défendre ça avec la structure regardez
la différence de structure si le pion et
angers troyes le la structure blanche
est complètement blindé le pion h3c la
seule différence avec le pion g6 et du
coup la structure blanche et disloqué et
le fou se régale pour ramener le roi en
g3 peut-être pour blinder tout ça mais
mais bon aux échecs c'est un de lui ça
vient du grand petrossian fait à zig ça
vient de tigran petrosyan mais pas celui
là en fait celui qui a été champion du
monde l'autre donc mais petrossian c'est
un nom très commun en arménien tigran un
prénom très commun donc d'où les
homonymes qui peuvent se rencontrer je
pense à mon avis à les pronos pour cette
première ronde de 1 pour les américains
je mettrai victoire
so victoire caruana et côté arménien
victoire petrossian tout petrosyan
d'ailleurs si on les biens me prononcer
on va voir en tout cas où ça nous mène
voulais rester sur quelle partie
petrosyan moi c'est un parti qui
m'intéresse le plus perso parce que
j'aime bien les trucs comme ça où ça
rentre où tu joues sur une bonne pièce
contre une mauvaise pièce ça me fait
kiffer may à la finale de tout aussi qui
me fait kiffer mai mais je me dis les
finales de tours c'est peut-être un peu
too much pour vous victoire de soe
victoire petrossian m c'est pas pour
dire mais c'est exactement la variante
que je vous ai montré les gars excusez
moi d'avoir dérangé
excusez moi d'avoir spoil c'est
exactement ce dont je vous parlais
c'était la variante logique à 100% et le
seul truc c'est après dame sait si c'est
ce que ces dames des 8 le coût est ce
qu'on fait un autre truc genre des
quatre avant pour éviter les dames c'est
cinq échecs
donc la france et sur dame c6 c'est
quasi sûr pascal 6g si ça fait pas sens
de le donner
donc dams et 6 à mon avis et là-dessus
peut-être des quatre pour mettre une
pression sur b5 et de toute façon se
dire que sur 1 dames 17 on aura dame c5
et on reviendra à choper le même chiper
je dirais le pion
le pion b5 ça sent bon je rejette un
oeil sur haïti il est dur à tenir salle
a34 un pion de moins maintenant il est
peut-être un pion - déjà en fait il a
filé un pion il a filé un pion parce
qu'il veut faire tout rejet 4h 4 et se
dire que c'est nul c'est très bien joué
les gars de la part de ike c'est très
très bien joué ça crisse de pions pour
l'activité alors sur dame set il a fait
j'ai six dames des huîtres wife cette
dame prend à 5
il n'y a pas d'échec pour les noirs
fassi adams et 5 mais c'est pas les
chèques qui te fait le plus peur tu peux
faire rage et de fourrage de fou g2a il
va la gagner un tigre anne hallé et ça
doit ni ses shows ouais c'est bouillant
les gars les arméniens qui sont là alors
est ce que tu fais b à tour g4 h4
honnête mois les temps d'accès tenir
être étant dax à tenir
elle est très temps d'accès à tenir les
gars parce que tour g4 il va faire wave
3 y aura pas de h4 alors attend
peut-être faut faire prise prise h 4g h
tours gkp hayatou rage 3 assez bien joué
ça a assez bien joué de la part de
wesley et il l'aura h 5h 6h 7h 8h c'est
tellement bien joué c'est tellement bien
joué c'est la partie mais c'est
tellement bien joué et j'ai acheté
tourache pas mais qu'est ce que c'était
bien joué le a3 les gars au la géométrie
parfaite de wesley à ça ça me fait
kiffer ça c'est le genre de coups qui me
font kiffer après faut vraiment être
amateur de finale et tout ça pour
apprécier mais c'est fini alors tour des
3 pourquoi pas à mes tournées 3 à 3 au 7
rue e 6 bon au pire il fait tourner ses
trois des six j'ai acheté tous rage 3
mais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
dollars la sqaf et wesley a été très
bien joué de la part de renac qui a filé
le pion h4 et qui s'activent de l'autre
côté
voilà il ya du ya du lait
la côte et tigran ça devrait gagner avec
sa majorité à la dame est maintenant
j'ai acheté tous rage 3 il a fait le
petit tour des trois échecs parce qu'il
a vu qu'ils avaient tour c3 et peut-être
que du coup 3e set était meilleure pour
gagner un tempo sur sur un chemin du roy
on va voir les gars en tout cas c'est un
beau symbole matin pour le moment c'est
un beau match c'est un beau match car on
va voir on va on va assurer à petrosyan
ouais bon petrosyan la victoire elle va
y aller juste ya peu de temps pour son
adversaire il va y aller doucement
il va pas se presser fait regardable c3
c'est peut-être le pire échange de dames
et quoi qu'ils auraient tous les pions
sur blanc ça va gagner mais dans tous
les cas ça va gagner l'euro arrivants b4
il va être obligé de mettre la marche
avant vallée ses côtés côté sadoine il
va se prendre des dames f2 échec qui ça
joue bien mais fabiano qui est en train
de mettre la pression et sow qui calcule
il refait tour des trois rois au système
poggi h tours j'ai ktef 3a il fait ça
comme ça torah choix me paraissait
tellement dangereux avec le pion âge qui
filait comme quoi je pense avoir une
bonne technique en finale mais pas de
pas tant que ça alors ça c'est gagnant
comment ça c'est gagnant comment est ce
qui veut dire que après tour c'est 3,3 g
5 tours france et 6 3 3 avec le pion
sait il est gagnant va pas falloir
dormir un côté côtes américains bon là
ça continue à presser avec des dames f6
vous prend 2,6 et fabiano il n'a pas
foulé si c'est hyper chaud on va rester
sur fabiano avec les noirs contre le
petit rhône ac mais ça doit ni moi il
m'avait complètement arnaquer près j'ai
pas le niveau de caruana c'est pas loin
loin de là la comparaison mais il
m'avait complètement arnaquer dans un
truc tactique il
il était monstrueux mais genre
monstrueux il et il y avait très mal
joué stratégiquement et quand c'est
devenu tactique il avait bu
ces 40 catégorie au dessus de moi donc
il peut être pénible
il peut être pénible à jouer à l'esad
oignies faut la tenir petit ça va passer
par des exploits pour les arméniens
toute façon pour pour la gagner c'est
tendu changer c'est qu'il n'ya pas un
damage deux dames h 1re avec deux dames
j'ai deux rois des trois dames f13 ces
trois fous 1 avec un roi qui seraient
bloqués à il semble un et l'ordi donne
quoi alors didonne +15 ouais ça veut
dire qu'il fallait reculer le fou en d5
pour protéger c'est exactement la vente
que je viens de vous dire je dis ça je
dis rien
pour moi ces trois fouilles excusez moi
de ce pôle et les partis mais ça c'est
fini on va regarder ensemble et là il ya
fou hein quand même sur route royale
fouet f2 et suroît et là il ya foule
faisait aussi d'âme des uns est fou et
trois échecs crois bien dame prend des
seins ça gagne tout seul à laisser
gagner pour fabiano petrossian qui la
gagnent aussi en envoyant son pur à 100
l'avez vu esso qui la gagne à lacets
finir on apprend aussi que ça va gagner
alors comment il a gagné ça aurait
scellé il n'a pas fait tout reprend f3
sûrement puisque le roi filet ouais ça
c'est fini
ouais gros gros gros début de match
américain et oui petit pont du sénat à
venir ike qui va abandonner
gros début de match de la part des
américains belle partie de petro sur un
câble qui a battu dominguez qui est
difficile c'est un joueur solide mais
amel a hélas il y peut rien
wesley ou ac c'est quand même ans et se
laisse aux joueurs du top mondial et ça
doit ni qu'elle avait les blancs mais
peut-on lui reprocher de perdre contre
le numéro deux mondial
ce qu'ils sont forts ces américains sec
c'est une armada que l'arménie en face
d'elle et huit dames au prochain le
petit ton lui sénat quelque part fait
par le roi qui gagne la partie et j'ai
envie de dire très beau très très beau
début de match les gâchez pas ce que
vous en avez pensé
mais le début de match est vraiment très
plaisant très très plaisant là ce
premier ce premier set
c'est sympa pour certains que
l'intensité va durer ouais on se tester
sympa et brodé gros début de match des
américains le match est beaucoup plus
serré que ce que j'aurais pensé
j'avais peur au début donc en gros c'est
qui qui a gagné en réalité ouais donc
les 3e et chi qui ont battu les
deuxièmes échiquier adverse et la
différence s'est faite wes et caruana
qui a battu ça doit ni et par am qui a
pas réussi à battre lyon mais bon ça
peut se comprendre ce que tu pars amis
n'étaient même pas favori contre guillon
qu'avec les noirs alors que caruana les
350 points l'autre plus quoi il ya les
arméniens vrai mais ça va être difficile
hein ça va être compliqué
leur gros problème en fait je dirais
c'est surtout la différence entre le
enfin il ya des problèmes partout et la
différence entre le les quatre en fait
les échiquiers numéro 4 parce que quand
quant à renac qui va se rendre en corse
au et dominguez diongue il va toujours
il va jamais être en difficulté c'est
vraiment en fait sur les trois premiers
si on veut que les trois premiers entre
eux la div serait déjà grosse mais quand
tu rajoutes le quatrième est chic et
dans l'équation ça devient sadien énorme
à mon avis on verra mais mais je vois
pas de retournement de situation dans ce
match les gars qui discute c'est
pourquoi carmona est rarement reconnue
comme une légende du jeu d'échecs alors
qu'il a un des taux les plus élevés
jamais atteints parce qu'il n'a jamais
été champion du monde néo sio quiz
réponse simple et efficace de champion
du monde est d'avoir un statut légende
temps n'était pas champion du monde
c'est difficile de donner un statut de
légende du jeu mais il n'était pas loin
gagner le titre a d'ailleurs contre
magnus si vous vous rappelez il a une
bonne partie je crois c'est la partie
numéro 9 ou l'a8 ça va être la 9 pouvait
être l'a9 peut-être où il a eu une
grosse position qu'il a raté il est pas
revenir nous sortions alors aronian ne
joue pas avec l'équipe d'arménie et
pourquoi ces actions je vous passe c'est
une grosse question parce qu'il avait
une énorme perf
évidemment il manque beaucoup au
quatrième échelon arménien ainsi que
andriatiana qui aurait pu aussi faire le
taf au quatrième et chic est donc je
sais pas pourquoi ces deux joueurs ne
jouent pas ça fait un moment qu'on les
voit plus trop dans les title tuesday
non plus mais honnêtement je ne connais
pas la raison je vous cache pas que j'ai
mes idées mais mais je connais pas la
raison officielle
on va voir comment ça va se passer mais
en tout cas gros gros début de match
écoutez mais on a vu des belles parties
quand même c'est assez agréable ça
envoyé un peu de partout c'était pas des
petites nul insipide
comme on a pu en connaître les autres
jours avec des matches qui étaient plus
en contrôle
je vais jeter un oeil aujourd'hui au
chat sur youtube va essayer de faire un
peu les deux pourvois
alors j'ai essayé de voir les deux
onglets voilà la lâche mme royal je suis
les deux chat comme ça ces gens parlent
un peu sur youtube jeu pour réussir et
agir
je vais me faire un truc je me fais un
truc pas mal si hennezel gagne pas les
candidatures vrai exploit qui à la place
kovy 19
du coup je sais pas maxime que soit le
covidien et les candidats il est bien
parti d'ailleurs un spot ico vite c'est
quand même un joueur quand même moi qui
a vu qui est né en 2019 et qui a quand
même un certain level il réussit à faire
à faire des choses il peut il peut
surprendre
malgré un hello annonce à 1900 il fait
mal
très solide de kobe doin il a beaucoup
progressé en peu de temps et ouais non
il surprend est-ce que tu devras fait
présent dans ce tournoi alors ouais
d'oberhof jouer pour répondre à
guillaume dans le chat de bronze jouer
pour une équipe russe je crois les
moscou wizard je crois les moscou wizard
qui ont été éliminés avant les avant les
demi finales quand reprennent les
matches écoute je crois qu'il ya entre
dix et quinze minutes de pause alors moi
je dirais que ça va reprendre à 19h40
mais à
mais peut-être ça va être 45 je ne sais
pas j'ai eu du mal tout la compétition
avoir vraiment une
une lecture correcte des horaires donc
on va voir les deux en or à la master
class avec vlad fin master class vladou
m us nous par une master class wadoux
montrera ses plus belles parties enfants
des news de l'équipe de france pour la
saison prochaine de pcl alors j'ai
toujours pas les règlements de la saison
prochaine de pcl et j'ai demandé s'il y
avait quelque chose officielle qui
pouvait être annoncée pour une nouvelle
saison ou pas et j'ai pas eu de réponses
on manie dit d'annoncer une nouvelle
saison de pro chess ligue ni dit de ne
pas annoncer de nouvelles saisons de
prod classe league donc je suis moi-même
dans l'expectative
il les a notés sur son carnet et anneaux
fakes d-box en fait elles sont dans le
carnet de vlad c'est parti
justement j'adore quand tu es avec la de
quartier comme un gosse est éclatée à
ses côtés bah ouais c'est un c'est un
très vieil ami vlad
on a fait les 400 coups ensemble on
s'entend vraiment très très très très
très très très bien
c'est comme un grand frère pour moi vlad
et du coup ça va forcément se ressentir
dans les vidéos parce que tout le temps
en train de se marrer quand on se voit
et mardi mazet fait le title c'est
toujours la question que je me pose de
mettre yogourt je sais j'avais moi-même
à l'avant sans fait donc je suis dans
l'expectative comme toi mais oui
forcément quand il ya blad bat c
c'est un ami très proche donc c'est un
feu chaque fois ça ça me fait plaisir de
la voir ça permet de bien se marrer là
malheureusement cette année on n'a pas
pu se voir à cause back aux ducs au vide
mais normalement plus tous les ans
passent une petite semaine ensemble
c'est très cool parce que jerry très
belle femme aux autres carnets c'est
probable je sais pas mais je pense oui
je pense je pense je pense c'est
quelqu'un qui hérite de sa wii enfin
parlons pas de malheur et j'espère
jamais à avoir en hériter de ce carnet
très proche et plus que vous ne le
pensez je peux raconter une petite
anecdote om joue axe mais mais en fait
on est tellement copains que son ex
l'ex-femme de vlad pensé qu'on avait une
relation avec va carrément petite
anecdote marrante
pour ceux qui sont venus voir la finale
de la pro jet li qui vous n'êtes pas si
nombreux que ça mais anecdote véridique
en fait ils sont beaucoup trop proche
j'ai toujours su mais quand la
différence d'âge
on a une dizaine d'années mais c'est
assez marrant ça nous avait bien fait
rire d'ailleurs
ça sera répétée des formes et amplifiée
en vrai c'est drôle ou ça vous a fait
marrer on a tellement rigolé avec ça on
a tellement rigolé avec ça tu peux
imaginer ça fait tellement rire
heureusement que son ex femme était pas
comme blague j'ai toujours dit j'ai
toujours su quoi est ce qu'on parle en
français ou en russe avec grade ça
dépend on est quand on en france on se
parlera us quand on en russie on se
parle français
évidemment dit les risées style vous
complètement complètement irrésistible
donc ouais ça ça dépend de
l'environnement fait mais quand on se
voit en france on parle systématiquement
russe mais et du coup après comme comme
j'ai réussi à apprendre tout à l'heure
on est on est beaucoup trop vulgaire
donc on protège on protège on protège
les alentours de notre de notre
vulgarité avec avec vlad en parlant dans
des langues étrangères
tu as appris comment le russe nommée
deep en allant russie si si vraiment en
fait j'ai appris le russe en allant
russie mais là c'est vraiment nos fake
j'ai mis 2 ans ou deux ans et demi a
commencé un peu à parler et à partir de
la troisième année ça allez ça allait
bien ça allait bien
grâce à la méthode d'apprentissage la
tcat chef en fait puisque c'est vrai
c'est ça le pire
et donc j'ai appris quelques chansons de
rap
russ parker et à et donc gt gt en
capacité de parler avec avec les gens là
en leur balançant des punchline comment
on dit quand je vois un trou j'y rentre
à cap d'ail et vie je vous dis rail afra
joue je dirais d'accueil d'avis vous
dire il ya frajou oui ça me paraît
normal rue et dans les anecdotes fast
fashion is true faith et je kiffe la
couleur non je parle que français et
russes et anglais
et comment je suis tombé sur vlad
je suis d'abord tombé sur son charme
gizmo et a notamment joué dans le même
club en fait quand j'étais à cannes les
meilleurs punchline oui on a beaucoup
faudrait demander à ludovic ça il y en a
plein des bonnes feuilles shine est un
peu espagnol ouais je disais que tu
étais ignorait complètement tout le
temps
même temps à savoir lire pour savoir le
cyrillique sans trop de souci j'ai mis
une heure à apprendre et après quelques
avec un peu d'entraînement le cyrillique
c'est facile c'est là la difficulté du
cyrillique en fait c'est que c'est léo
qui se lisent à etc les mots qui en fait
qui se lisent pas pareil qui se prononce
forcément non le cyrillique en vrai
c'est facile c'est de l'eau c'est
vraiment le truc le plus facile en russe
en fait de lire le cyrillique
je garde encore ses accents sauveterre
d'arrêt mais moi je galère encore
maintenant enfin jeu j'en ai absolument
rien à faire des alliances et des
accents soft ou pas sauf qu'en fait ça
ne m'intéresse pas en fait la langue
russe écrite est difficile moi je sais
lire mais je sais pas l'écrire c'est
trop difficile pour moi
je préfère de loin les accents art or
ici je cherchais restaurant ouais alors
ça s'écrit plus tôt comme ça si tu
voulais faire restaurer ce serait comme
ça comme j'ai écrit françois jacq
enfin même comme ça plus tôt ouais c'est
vrai nous serait le pee le s le thé le
rôle er à ennery wes écrit comme ça tu
as vécu dix ans en russie tu sais pas
écrire russe ah ouais non c'est trop dur
enfin je sais pas écrire
j'étais avec ma femme en russe sur wat
sapin si tu veux savoir 1 mais à mes
jeux sujet une très mauvaise grammaire
et je fais beaucoup de fautes
d'orthographe
après écrire je sais écrire quand même
faut pas non plus abuser peter restera
donc j'ai pensé à la même chose que toi
il se vole haut c'est beau [ __ ] peter
fecteau pas quoi j'ai pensé à la même
hausse extraordinaire assez
extraordinaire tu as pensé à la même
blague que moi peter picto pas joli bon
c'est là qu'on va voir ça reprend à
40,45 fait ça reprendra 46 mètres le
truc un peu en avance par rapport aux
biens et donc ses 40 normalement ouais
non sinon c'est à 48 est ce que j'ai
déjà dormi dans le même lit que vlad oui
oui c'est sûr ça ça c'est sûr je ne sais
pas à qui à l'occasion mais oui c'est
sûr
pour sortir dans le métro ouais alors
pour sortie dans le métro c'est c'est ça
ce serait comme ça c'est comme ça sur
six dans le métro non c'est même comme
ça en fait à temps ouais c'est comme ça
avec un grand b pour réussir à le faire
avec un clavier à lanus et difficile et
en plus c'est pénible parce qu'en fait
vivre de ses sorties et frotte ses
entrées non mattia que une lettre de
différence qui est ce on y va quand même
pas inquiet c'est pas un istin y que
j'arrête j'ai toujours du mal à dire en
gros c'est un saint ou un peu bizarre y
fermer et du coup en fait il ya que
cette lettre qui changent l'entrée de la
sortie donc parfois c'est parce que tu
peux retrouver
tu peux être dans le métro et qui est la
sortie sortie et puis qui est une entrée
vers un autre métro aussi donc si jamais
tu te plantes que tu vois pas bien la
lettre ou quoi tu tues tu peux ne pas
sortir mais rentrait vers une autre
station qui annexe de la tienne en fait
vous connexes plus tôt
son meilleur niveau et mvl aujourd'hui
qui a eu son meilleur niveau annuel de
loin
mais non cuit dans le métro ce peut être
galère en fait donc je relance les
quatre partis on va regarder ça jacasse
les tchats olalla dominguez qui va jouer
une berlinoise assad oignies bonne
chance renac la nvelle fadlallah était
très fort mais mvl c'est encore une
autre catégorie de joueurs aiment faire
at il atteint son meilleur niveau
sûrement pas à baky 1,83 à mai ont
demandé une belle aujourd'hui ou vlad à
son meilleur niveau
d'ailleurs demain mais très important la
master class à 20h30 baky meilleur parti
de vlad les meilleures parties qui l'a
retrouvé dans un carnet qui était chez
lui dans un coffre quoi ça c'est quelque
chose quoi c'est ça et du très haut
niveau
l ancien numéro deux mondial ray numéro
quatre actuels et futurs en numéros un
ce qui intrigue sur la chaîne ce soir je
pense pas un mot qu'on ait eu
l'autorisation de la patronne mais là je
crois pas là
en 2001 ils exposeront ce carnet dans
les musées way n'ont même pas ils se
roulent dans 2000 ans ce carnet sera
dans un aéroport enfin sera même plus
des aéroports quoi dans on va appeler ça
des aéroports intergalactique
dans les endroits où on entrepose les
tableaux voilà maintenant dans celui du
mec le plus cher le plus riche de la
galaxie il y aura ce petit carnet quoi
voilà faut le savoir
parham contre mad max ou de loups ça
fait quoi c'est un gambit damas non ça
ça fait une vague auzines parlons pas
n'importe quoi pas une drag queen
c'est juste un candidat en fait tu la
prends c'est que n'importe quoi ok a par
am donc avec les blancs comptent wesley
ça va être chaud rona coquet petit
garçon l'avait vu caruana contre tigran
c'était une car aux calendes avance
donc fabiano contre tigran on va voir ce
que ça donne mon c'est là car au cannet
nous restait martirossian c'est quoi ça
martirossian contre jefferies média 6
qui arrive trois qu'ils ici ce qui est
d'accord c'était c'est un genre de
tshing auryn j'aime bien les noirs je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez les gars
il n'y a pas de [ __ ] cases noires pour
attaquer le roi et ça va partir à base
de ces cinq c4 b5 bekkat avec le carré
lisse et s'être bien placé ça m'a l'air
le ki67 il est tellement bien placés en
vrai c'est tellement ouvre ce gars est
mvl aujourd'hui vs kasparov à son
meilleur niveau
faut demander à baky mais je pense que
kasparov un peu au dessus mais je suis
pas sûr parce qu'il ya eu quand même eu
l'évolution le niveau qui augmentait
mais là il n'y a pas juste c'est cinq c4
b5 bkt tu te fais tu t'es pas en train
de te faire nettoyer la le ki67 il est
génial il défend des cinq n'a jamais de
problème t'as pas de vendre leurs prises
prise prises des 5 puisque s'est défendu
deux fois tu peux pas le gagner et quand
tu vas faire cesser quatre baies 5 ta
pâte qui prend b5 fait il te protège les
deux pions importants
il est monstrueux qui a laissé cette
ces 5
ces cinq sites des 5
je suis en train de réfléchir mais là il
ya puis on passe à long terme en b 4 mai
mais attaque éventuellement sur le roi
je pense qu'en réalité ici les arméniens
peuvent prendre le tarot
prendre le tarot
bon j'ai régis par an ça doit ni en fait
en me disant je vais être gelé peut être
rayé de la carte trop tôt en me disant
berlinoise contre dominguez ça va être
chaud on va voir mais eux mais en fait
j'ai hyper peur dans cette partie enfin
je trouve que avec avec les blancs et
une position désespérante horrible ban
envie de vomir de voir ça je n'ai pas de
petit sac pour vomir en quatre parties
comme ça
donc ça par am en fait j'ai toujours
peur parce qu'ils jouent contre eux
souvent vrai sinon à la positionne me
paraît tout à fait correct on me
dominguez des bons en berlinois dre de
me caser très bon berlinoise ils
petrosur vais je sais pas fayard aussi
les noms qui font peur parce que tu dis
quand même car rooney avec les blancs
comptent petrossian ça peut très bien se
passer pour pour caruana quoi donc je
suis un peu inquiet les gars je suis un
peu inquiet parce que disons là ça peut
vraiment là là ça peut vraiment faire
très très chère très très vite en fait
2000 gaye sarr monstre en rapide et en
longue aussi un domingas c'est un
monstre tout court
il veut faire plus faire cavalier prend
matin car ayant des quatre en a je pense
que l'arménie aujourd'hui alors à deux
lettres de personnes wenzhou axe
l'arménie en grande difficulté à mon
avis l'aso et commence à pressuriser le
centre et la case 2,5 pour le cavale
situe pas dans une case envie tu dis
qu'il est nul ou il bien sûr ça va être
valises 1 je suis d'accord avec toi baky
base tu fous là c'est toi qui es
d'accord avec ce que j'ai dit mais ça me
fait plaisir de de la sentir comme baky
ça ça peut ça peut faire à mon avis ça
peut faire trois et demi 1/2 voire même
4-0 enfin sens sans rigoler ça peut ça
peut vraiment faire très très cher cette
ronde là je
comment il a fait pour un peu l'ami qui
la famille qui moi j'avais le maquillage
et femmes et ike il un peu je pensais
qu'il ferait ses quatre baies 5 en vrai
et il a fait à 5 qui avait laissé un a4
a3 prise prise f5
peut-être qu'il peut réussir à faire
cavalier b5 et changer eux et faire
cavalier à deux cavaliers c3 et scipion
prend des quatre mètres le fond des
trois est bloquée et après repartir avec
car il y eu deux cavaliers j'ai un
cavalier ff3 cavaliers au 5 mai ce qui
fait ça me paraissait plus grave ces
quatre baies 5 un jeu plus direct
bon ça me paraît quand même grave hein
ne me faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas
dis ah mais attendez à pas jusqu'à va
les prendre il faut prendre il faut
prendre des quatre enquêtes
avec maintenant ça paraît désespérance
et sur francis histoire d'éviter
vêtements et ses gènes ses katas pardon
j'ai pas vu le pion le pion le front des
quatre enfants quand même pas abandonné
1 mais faut pas voir la souris doit
faire ses positions là faut essayer de
tenir un temps tiendra quelques unes
dans les joints sert à rien abandonné et
a rien de moins et est peut-être qu'il
ya des trois quarts a lieu cinq ans fait
son plan ce que moi je voulais passer
par à de ces 3 et 6 prenez repartir
après mais peut-être tu t'en fiches du
fait qu'il y ait des trois cavaliers aux
kiev 3
un lieu sain caf 4 mai fille sage sur
cases noires mais bon tu arriveras pas à
pousser parce qu'il ya foule et trois
cas et c4 a laissé peut-être pas si
grave peut-être que je veux pas york et
blanc de son mieux mais peut-être qu'on
a peut-être qu'on a un peu peut-être
qu'on a un peu un peu un peu noirci le
tableau
peut-être qu'ils vont juste prendre deux
et demi un ennemi parce qu'il est laid
ce range
voilà ça doit ni ne sait pas trop ce
qu'il fait mais je comprends pas trop
les berlinois n'ont pas trop rester
dessus ou peut-être fou 3 kf4 vous
[ __ ] wildcat fc un niveau au large
avec h5 bon ça doit ni qu'il résiste
bien et a fait rage 5 je pense à est
sûre j'ai 5 g 6 6 blocs et sinon il
s'ouvre la colo et il joue pas mal ça
doit ni il s'est trouvé du jeu
caruana
je pense qu'on a influencé par les noms
aussi là quand on regarde et salue jarod
83 13
salut à toi peut-être à me2 tour des 1
c'est l'idée des noirs c'est pareil
quand même pas mal
faut faire gaffe de passes faire
réseauter mais à quel un pion plus pour
le moment on est parti jusqu'à qu'à
l'heure alors je crois que c'est 2h40
les matches on va commencer à 19h 21h 40
moi j'aime bien comment il joue aussi à
renac
salut à spaggiari si j'ai déjà dit
bonjour fait quand je chante on calcule
en même temps or kébé ça ne s'est pas
les prendre le pion honnêtement il ya un
truc que j'ai pas vu c'est tout donc
j'ai pas pu bien analysé le truc j'ai
pas vu une variante très clairement donc
il a fait çà çà çà çà çà
écoutez c'est plus si clair c'est plus
si claire lecavalier a eu cinq là il est
beau ouais bah ouais je sais pas là ça a
tout bien tournée de partout pour pour
les galbes acquis sadoine il est super
bien mais à la partie d'occasions que ça
qui m'étonne le plus que je pensais que
ça allait mais être m'attend 25 ou ça me
rappelle c'est une vieille partie favier
partie fans ont même fait d'aller
nouvelle mais une partie baartman prague
amanda qui avait très mal tourner pour
barman attendait une propos de nul ça
c'est intéressant on va chercher ou ac
ça doit ni qui propose nul un peu comme
il l'avait fait hier alors attention
dominguez prépare toi parce que quand
ils proposent une généralement après
c'est finir c'est ça va bien se passer
j'imagine que la ligne c'est quoi ces
cas et des 5es et des cinq ou même pions
des cinq nankin et cinq noms pile tourbe
et un bout des quatre boucles des quatre
et trois sets 3-6 avec le caribéen
installant des caméras peut-être des ces
quatre pages à jour et moi avec les
blancs quand même celle là mais
peut-être fou des cats et peut-être où
des cas de ses hits quant à la foulée de
caisse et 3 double tour b 1
inquiet peut-être mais quand même ça qui
est attaqué
bon à voir c'est un peu tôt pour nulle
wave 1 je sais pas c'est pas idiot hier
il a un peu utilisé ce stratagème aussi
et ça lui a plutôt réussi
scooby doo sow contre parham mais
attends c'est qu'ici c'est passé la came
là ça tourne super bien pour parham il
ya pion de plus et le pion j'ai ici six
réseaux tu attends mais c'est en train
de vraiment bien tourné de partout c'est
en
train de bien tourner de partout bon ça
c'est chaud mais je sais que je me
répète lab la partie dice et par rapport
à la poubelle qui avait tout à l'heure
ce que la sage ou complètement voilà
mais je préfère même les blancs tu as
l'impression que tu es 4 pions ils sont
durs à avancer les pions doublé ils sont
bien placés là et que les blancs ils
vont jouer ils vont prendre la colonne
des cibles et si ça va être gagné mon
hockey
c'est chaud dame b3 qui le tour prend
des huit dames 3e 6 très tendue et c'est
pas dit que ça allait si bien touax a
pris ses huit reprises ses 8 3 7 kg 5
roy h6 ouais c'est hyper chaud à malte
et chypre ont eu six qui menacera
tourache huit matches mais bon tour d un
contre échec crois-je deux dames propre
regard des genres de variantes c'est
hyper compliqué c'est le feu à elle
alors dit que c'est gagnant pour les
blancs à cause de f4 trouvable attaque
la dame et menaces maths et il n'ya pas
d'un pronom si ses protégés
ah oui trouvable trouvable trouvable il
accepte nuls dominguez incroyable ce ca
douaniers quand même
ouais c'est une belle nul là dans la
dans la berlinoise faire nul contre un
gars du top 15 mondial comme ça bien
joué ça doit ni fabiano il va réussir à
haïr tap le pion g6 c'est temps dax de
chez temps dax croissait temps dax de
partout
et finalement c'est peut-être ike qui
est bien quand il a échangé sa il a fait
g4 et il allait changer bon d'accord
cette partie là qu'est la patate chaude
la caruana et ce qui va trouver le
cavalier g5 comprend aussi sur tours d1
dames 35 f 4c trouvable s'y trouvent
site
j'essaie un courage qui va lui aussi se
tasse à attaquer tu mets un échec et
comment tu défends à l'endroit il est
vraiment malin il a fait tourner ses
seins il a raté olala le cioc de caruana
c'était quand même trouvable ça bon moi
j'avais le redis je sais pas pour dire
mais franchement c'était kg cinq
cavaliers aussi ça avec les maths en h
suite après et peut-être d'autres
variantes mais c'était dans le domaine
du trouvable ce qu'une fois que tu as vu
le f4 en fait tu comprends que yahya
jammeh déchets quand on veut 5 ha ça
peut faire tourner le match ça il fait
roi s'il évite les cavaliers g5
oui puisque là c'était points pour en
fait c'était c'était fini mv elle aurait
trouvé après c'était pas facile hein les
gars moi je vous dis j'avais l'ordi à
une fois qu'on voit c'est facile mais en
partie c'est dur à voir cependant le
fait de rater un gain comme ça et d'être
maintenant dans une position bas qui est
plutôt à l'avantagé des norias pions
plus sa fin ils peuvent passer de
victoire saint louis à victoire arménie
c'est ça
une énorme dit tu peux passer un moment
donné elle a tué au lieu de faire 4-2 ça
pourrait faire 3-3 c'était trouvable
c'était vraiment trouvable ici c'est
tellement le feu tactique
tu as une qualité qui va se perdre là tu
as les pions passer de l'autre côté
c'est le feu mais je pense que c'est
plutôt bien pour parham ça soit le feu
est ici c'est n'importe quoi mais ça a
l'air d'être très bien pour martirossian
parce que quand tu vas faire tour des
huit tours des cas tu va échanger les
tours et dames fou ça attaque beaucoup
moins bien que dame tour bon c'est chaud
un bail c'est chaud parce qu'il va
perdre le contrôle du pion ces trois
jours c'est très très chaud je prendrai
f4 par réflexe
amy adams et 3 et d'emprunts b4 nan nan
nan tu prends le cas tu es obligé tu es
obligé de prendre quatre tél
j'aime prendre quatre t'as pas le choix
attendant
cat échec aussi pardon pas le choix et
d'amd cas tu protèges c3i pro 4 tu as
quand même envie de le prendre ce que
deux pions passé lié ça fait mal au c
bouillant les gars c'est bouillant de
partout je refais un petit tour
petrossian ces gros yachts de plus
maintenant parham c'est n'importe quoi
est-ce que tu dois prendre des trois
prises détroit et laisser les deux pions
passé je pense pas se sentait obligé
d'avancer un an
dames 1 et tours b 1
damas 3 tours b2 et tu fais nul
peut-être bon c'est complètement fou les
gars à mes petrossian 3 petrossian qui
va la gagner mais là il va faire h3c
c'est dead lecavalier sous pressions et
menaces age 2 h
il fait tour à 3 ah ouais y'a pas ya
papillon prends parce que cavalier prend
et il gagne la cale à la tour et tour à
un tour à 2 aya qu'avait lieu encore ça
défend un peu bon mais ça doit gagner on
va on va retourner par amiens a par am
ses pions de plus il a réussi à nettoyer
l'échiquier ils sont plus en danger les
arméniens et alors ici assez perpète est
en train de se faire avec
ah non il ya juste eu roi c1 dames à 3
tours b deux dames à un tour b 1
damas 3 ça doit faire nul et donc
petrosyan ol petrosyan qui gagne ouh là
là là là je vous dédie un bon écart one
halak a raté un gros truc donc victoire
de l'arménien et maintenant maintenance
après ce côté par âme et sa presse côté
côté terrien côté martirossian voilà jeu
en ce que toute personne saine d'esprit
joue tour b2 mais il peut partir pour
roi des rois 1 ce qui fondamentalement
t'es peut-être gagnant il l'attend
aouita tour d2 qui peut revenir pardon
pardon pardon j'avais pas vu ouais les
arméniens qui remonte la nes est parti
quand même de sept nuls de sa doit ni
contre dominguez avec les noirs et
exigeons qui fait et tours d2 est
exigeant qui fait une mauvaise partie il
n'a pas vu tour des dogues faire 3 8
tempo ou alors il a vu mais d'emprunt f4
alors maintenant se fait quoi bref les
qualités net de plus mais alors là les
types alors là les types celle là elle
est monstrueusement compliquée à jouer
c'est ça doit être beaucoup mieux pour
les blancs parce que les tours c'est
plus fort mais c'est chaud
c'est très chaud roi c'est un art il va
cacher droit assure dan b2 il ya
toujours eu en maths
fatou re 1 et d'un noeud 3 ouais ça à
faire perpète
ça va faire nul pas le choix ok donc ça
va faire trois et demi trois et demi est
ici ouais ça c'est complètement nul
parce que ça va échanger les pions il
car elle y viendra sacrifier safra nul
donc ça va faire 4 4 normalement à moins
que vision glaçante mais non il va pas
tenter ça nulle signé parra mais il n'y
a pas de monde où tu gagne cette finale
mais même si c'est normal de la tournée
après je dors mal de la joie un peu hein
mais surtour b2 il y avait juste dame un
tour b à damas trois un robin des bois
le truc c'est que là ya pas il n'y a pas
de monde avec tes change des cavaliers
trois échecs si ça marche pas ça c'était
bien joué elle a t'oblige la prise quand
même ce que j'ai trois cavaliers f3 t'as
pas envie de le voir et ça c'est nul à
automatique
si les cas ils s'échangent c'est nul
tout tout tout est nul ça fait 2-2 ça
fait 2-2 avec petrossian qui sort un
gros match petrossian 2 sur 2 contre
caruana et dominguez gros début de match
de petrossian qui est bouillant il
recolle
et maintenant ça va être chaud crêpes en
fait quoi que tu prennes dans l'ordre
que tu les prennent en fait les
américains c'est c'est chaud c'est très
chaud donc américain et côté américain
et côtes américains et arméniens en vrai
c'est les échiquiers numéro deux qui
sont en difficulté ça douaniers avec un
demi quand même aux 4 face au monstre il
a joué c'est plutôt bien et côtes
américains maia il ya un écart one a
peut-être kibaki est passé un peu à côté
là il a raté le gain contre petrossian
quand même à noter que petrossian a
vraiment eu beaucoup de réussite en
parce que ceux-ci caruana fekkai g5 qui
avait lui aussi c'est qu'ils voient le
f4 c'était fini 1 donc petrossian qui a
la réussite et c'est là-dessus fin bref
en réalité 5 3 serait le score logique
fin avec etienne d'ailleurs on pensait
que cette ronde là ce sera un carton en
faveur des américains
on va voir mais quatre partout c'est
bouillant là c'est bouillant
c'est vraiment compliqué de de dire
qu'il va gagner les américains restent
bien évidemment favoris mais bon
petrossian qui avait classement mondial
il et 2600 il doit être aux alentours de
la 200e place mondiale
donc sans cesse et c'est chaud c'est
chaud c'est vraiment vraiment match
agréable à suivre en espérant que ça
continue comme ça de ce 60e mondiale
petrossian ouais il a dû il a dû il a dû
être mieux classé mais oui c'est vote
allait vérifier le scooby doo de toute
façon mais oui c'est ce soit à peu près
ce que je pensais il ya beaucoup de
joueurs de toute façon dans ce règne là
à 2006
on va voir les bacs
à 5,83 c'est le bretteur boys et c'est
pour être le vrai tienne c'est le
retiendrait ces parias pas un fou
etienne qui arrivent et non pas du tout
ça lui chie comme usain donc ça doit
reprendre 40 va savoir prendre à 20h20
bons pronostics alors les gars
larramendy quand même surprenante qui
ressort encore un gros match par micki
ne sort que des gros matches et qui en
sort un de nouveau le line up des
américains est quand même assez
impressionnant indique si tu es obligée
de cuinchy et plus creuser le wee cc par
ordre d lowell toute façon après c'est
un tout rond de zig ans et tout le monde
joue contre tout le monde
on va voir on va voir on va voir ça ça
va être ça va se jouer maintenant les
gars il reste plus de deux ans dans
cette pro chelsea qu'ils avaient les
arméniens qui sont impressionnants en
fait ils ont joué la deuxième saison il
avait gagné la troisième saison il était
déjà allé en demi finale il avait perdu
et quand c'est dans la super demi finale
qui se jouait hier elle est hélas cette
saison il arrive encore en finale ils
sont très réguliers aussi un ils sont
non seulement forme aussi très régulier
une petite question à quand je suis
presque mineurs lots sur check point
comme je trouve que le niveau est assez
élevée par rapport à tes vidéos sur les
parties pédagogique aux mêmes lots
seller partie pédagogique aux mêmes lots
qui sont élevés ou les housses que tu
rencontres toi ichigo mu n wen ont ils
sont très très réguliers sont très
réguliers ouais le le mou botte de
chasse comme il est un peu spéciale
après ils ont réglé pareil sur toutes
les chaînes de tous leurs trucs donc là
dessus il a mangé pas du tout 2 gp
d'espagne tout pouvoir sur leur
mouvement tant fait mais ah oui il est
un peu spécial heures vous battre mais
je suis d'accord que après préfère trop
ban que pas assez mais c'est spécial
c'est spécial
alain
savoir plus fort ah oui mais c'est parce
que moi en fait ça paraît simple parce
que je t'explique
en fait j'ai limite tous les coups qui
vont pas marché qui sont logiques par le
calcul et ça je le dis pas c'est un peu
un secret de magicien quoi mais en vrai
il ya plein de choses qui pourraient
paraître est logique et qui marchent pas
et que je joue pas du coup et vu qu un
coup aux échecs ça change tout
toute la dynamique de la partie
évidemment évidemment il suffit que tu
te trompes une fois macha et puis ça
marche plus du tout ça vient de ça moi
j'ai eu m atch eskom effet rejeté sur
l'île chef 1600 1700 et je plafonne à
1300 à 1400 ouais c'est normal qu'ils
chassent et est très généreux pour le
vélo et chaises comme l' inverse
donc ça a la même valeur en fait c'est
pas parce que tu as plus des lots
quelque part que tu es plus fort ou
moins fort chaise comme match com et
plus donne moins de points aux gens quoi
tout bêtement
tout simplement je fais un petit truc
pendant la pause
ça c'est bon est-ce que ce possible ne
peut pas eu autre chose comme avec les
loups dans la voix une anse pas vraiment
possible ça le tce est plus proche du
code fidh où sa défense dépend de
beaucoup de facteurs un robin des bois
j'ai du mal à répondre comme ça donc ça
va reprendre à 20h20 donc dans sept
minutes
est ce que tu penses que la prod
classique va essayer de refaire ce qu'il
a fait avant pour redresser le niveau
entre les clubs à avoir un taux moyen
des équipes favorites et après c'est
l'un des joueurs non je pense pas
british je pense qu'ils sont partis dans
un mode où ils vont vouloir faire un
truc un peu esport vous savez de plus en
plus que les meilleurs qu'ils ont joué
je peux me tromper mais à mon avis ça à
part faire là dedans
salut willy 10
je dise ça doit reprendre à 20h20 dans
sept minutes ouais je jouais au tbc pas
pareil que je vais sur un échiquier
c'est pas pareil que jouant en ligne
après si tu es bon en ligne t bonds sur
un échiquier ses ventes sur un an et 8
était bon ligne yappa des gars qui sont
1200 en ligne ea et 2005 sur un
échiquier très clairement à
sarr est vrai que les joueurs très
faible comme icare ou qui ont dépassé
les 3000 les avatars d'internet sont
passés au dessus de 3000 qui restent
ouais il va il va rester il va rester
deux rondes
deux fois 4 parties et en cas de 8,8
il y aura le gros tie break où il y aura
échec et 4 contres échiquier 4 à chaque
fois qu'on gagne pas une partie on est
éliminé donc en cas de nul les deux
joueurs sont éliminés et sinon celui qui
perd sort
on va voir
il reste quelques minutes à attendre
est ce que tu penses que six sites
partenaires ea sports et les temps en
ligne continue à tourner le lot sur la
table va finir par devenir sérieux pas
tant qu'il n'ya pas d'arbitré domicile à
la citrouille chan pas possible du coup
qui a le titre tiffany pour suivre le
live de gala et je vais rater le live de
gaël c'est vrai j'arrive en retard mais
pas après la guerre j'espère écoute
c'est un beau match maxime pour la peine
belle finale pour moi il ya quatre
partout les arméniens qui résistent bien
et qui ont beaucoup de réussite dans une
partie avec fabiano qui a raté un gain
qui était qui n'était pas simple
mais qui était trouvable et il a perdu
la partie du coup on va dire que en
réussissant y aurait en réussissant sa y
aurait 5 3 pour pour saint louis et là
il ya 4,4 donc ça ça fait ça ça laisse
les arméniens en vie quoi bon c'est
quand même plutôt saint louis qui a
dominé les arméniens qui restent qui
reste en vie mais il pourrait passer
l'accélérateur
je peux montrer la position et voir si
maxime trouve on peut le faire si je
veux après si je mets la position après
ils cherchent s'il veut chercher ils
cherchent patio pas chercher en fait ils
essaient de position et il a réfléchi
pas mal de temps avant de faire à avant
de rentrer dans les échanges qu'il a
réfléchi genre deux minutes là dessus on
va faire beau c'est maxime bon après
c'est un gain relatifs 1 ça continue à
jouer il y avait il y avait des défenses
plus forte je pense pour pour le joueur
arméniens mais n'ont presque pas le
faire maxime le fait pas il n'ya pas de
mal apposition comme cette façon une
position clé du match
ça s'arrête
combien le premier à 8 points et demi à
gagner le match wes kg 5e épreuve this
way est en fait à mon avis qu'il fallait
voir c'était tour des indes un rouage 2
et là il ya plus gros échecs comme un
atout rage suite maths et sur dames 35
ya fkt lecavalier protéger il n'y a pas
de tout rachat roi prend h 1 kg 3 ou
même dames 1 on va dire d'hamelin
peut-être plus chaud puisque roitg de
yap adam g iii ouais je pense que c'est
ce que j'ai dit maxime aux commentaires
qui la verra tfk toi est ce que j'ai
pensé mais toi tu vois c'est juste pour
dire que parce que je sais qu'avec
l'arménie voyais pas toujours avoir des
doutes ou quoi mais la main tout de même
qu'à roanne ac avait une position
gagnante et c'est quand même pas sorcier
de voir caler g5 et prend aussi c'est le
f 4 à la fin aymen pas besoin tu qu'elle
soit protégée à tours à huit matches
quand même oui tout à fait paraison pour
moi pour moi c'est un gros c'est un gros
raté de la part de caruana qweb avait on
réfléchisse en deux minutes deux minutes
35 ans en réalité kg 5 et prend ici
c'est ce qu'on regarde en premier parce
qu'on donne à ce match moi ce que je
vous dise que la voilà la ligne qu'on
regarde en premier tour d un rouage deux
là il ya un seul échec c'est d'un point
qu'on menace des maths et si on voit f4
s'est tout de suite finie
sur dame un retourné à son importance
alors ça en réalité j'ai pas vu damien
roy ch 2 mai sur d'un procès qui a quand
même f4 à huy et d'un prince six tours à
schwyz j'ai compris ce que tu disais
maxime hockey maxime c'est bien entendu
le level au dessus mais une fois que tu
as trouvé f4 tu le trouve quand même
dans tous les cas une fois que tu as vu
avec 4 tu l'as vu ce que ça avec toi je
suit après tu trouves
bon en tout cas c'est celle pas le
tournant du match pour le mans c'est ce
qui permet aux arméniens d'être d'être
encore en piste quoi c'est ce qui leur
permet d'être encore en vie dans ce
match on va voir si ça leur permet de de
faire le hold up du siècle et de le
gagner
en tout cas en tout cas ils sont là et
caruana enfin voila je me répète mais je
trouve que c'est un gros raté de sa part
intuitif shamir ah ouais c'est ça c'est
que c'est même moi quand je vais montrer
avant tout c'est la vente que que tu
avais envie de continuer à organiser
cinq épreuves cinq ans mais les noms ont
fait retour d'un échec 3 h deux temps
prend 2,5 ha oui mon bail avec 4 mai
mais c'était vraiment là bas on s'était
tous les coups logique presque il a
vraiment raté ça ou quelque chose
d'autre ça on peut pas le savoir mais
mais cesser le plus vraisemblable c'est
ce qu'il y a de plus vraisemblable et
maxime jours à la brawn de deux reprises
des candidats contre les noirs contre
les noirs contre fabiano caruana avec
les noirs bon ben haddou il a juste raté
le f4 alors ça devrait reprendre il est
21 ah ouais ça a repris sa pas manquer
ça qu'il n'ouvre pas les parties
directement quand on parle d'une chose
et d'une autre on s'en sort pu alors ça
doit ni maintenant il a de nouveaux les
noirs ils doublent les noirs bon il se
joue cette cela y joue contre le double
en piéton et le truc que je vous super
mal avec les noirs du coup la partie
m'intéresse
bon ça c'est l'ouverture on va voir
comment ça joue ses parties longues mais
avec un petit pression côté blanc c'est
eux qui ont qui ont plus la main sur le
centre
ça c'est une variante des changes de a
slave annonce passionnant en échange de
cela oui c'est ça de variante où on a
poussé ces cinq et on obtient une bonne
vente des changes la sapar dont on a
déjà vu hier côté côté arménien donc ces
petites pressions fou des trois
supérieurs aux fauves et 7 mai fu
bessette confère la case 4o au noir donc
des fois des cavaliers 4 ça a changé le
fourrier en d5 jefferies xiong contre
petrossian alors c'est sûr sa petite
pire qu un petrossian a l'impression que
c'est déjà kata mais bon hilton
tellement de cases mais il ajoute bien
après donc je lui fais confiance
et là ça peut être un point sensible
pour dominguez parce qu'il est pas en
forme il a fini avec les blancs il a été
dominé alors là qu'est ce qu'on a vu
comme parti a pas longtemps dans cette
position où le joueur avec les blancs
avaient joué ses trois on va voir si
vous suivez il ya un français bien connu
dans le milieu qui a joué ses trois ici
a pas longtemps lequel si ça répond dans
le chat après il a fait cas et b d2 qui
a laissé cinq c3 et des cats maintenant
c'est complètement une autre variante je
veux le nom des deux joueurs
je veux le titre complet de la partie
every man ray exactement
bon ça je connais pas la théorie ici
mais c'était une grande variante là donc
c'est ça c'est ses positions et je pense
toujours qu'à son pays maggio avec les
noirs pharma j'ai du mal à les jouer
l'atout revient en c1 et les blancs vont
te faire une expansion allait droit
je trouve ça systématiquement pénible
mais ça doit ni contre source anonyme va
quand même falloir qu'ils s'accrochent 1
pour annuler contre wesley so ici ça va
pas être facile je vous le dis tout de
suite il va falloir se lever de bonne
heure côté côté wesley
ça va être très chaud
ouais ça y va fort la tenir
est-ce que tour c1 c'est un coup pour se
remettre en phase de la dame et replacer
les tours comme ça face aux colonnes qui
peuvent s'ouvrir peut-être tourer pour
eux 4 mais à quand tu veux 4 tu
réveilles le fou bessette
on va voir ses positions que je vous mal
avec les deux couleurs de fassa pourquoi
il n'a pas pris 2 e mmc qu'il a pris de
près la paperie de c'est peut-être tu
prends de ces tu te fais rentrer sur la
colonne c'est sûrement en prenant 2 e
du coup tu étais plus solide et b4 ici
j'aime bien mais après tu as le plan b5
et b6 qui c'est quatre ici aussi qui
peut exister ce à un coût intéressant
d'herbes et cinq dans cette structure ce
qu'on est dans une structure type
carlsbad maintenant j'arrête
et dans cette souris de type carlsbad le
plan de ramener le carillon c4 peut être
fort et il le fait d'ailleurs bons
joueurs à rim dans le chat est à 5
maintenant pour les bleus pour les
blancs l'idée c'est d'empêcher qu'il y
avait 6 kgs c4 très bien joué de la part
de saut il avait évidemment calculé à
l'avancé très bien joué de la part de
saut alors maintenant le seul plan pour
faire ça c'est qu'à value8 qui est des
six qui haïssez 4 mai sur calais des
huit il doit y avoir eu quatre
c'est souvent le problème
c'est très souvent le problème ouais ok
un peu mieux pour ce autre façon ça fait
peur ici ike contre fabiano bon c'est
plus agréable à jouer pour haïti mais
fabiano cas normalement il va pas perdre
celle là param param contre les inner
dominguez c'est bizarre à dire mais
c'est sûrement là que les arméniens veut
le faire le point c'est à cet endroit là
qu'ils ont le moins de différences et
l'eau et en plus ils ont les blancs et
parham un excellent joueur de rapides
dominguez est en méforme il est qu un et
deux messieurs à 1/2 pardon sur deux il
a perdu bon que le petit rhône à qui il
a fait une contre le petit rhône à qui
il a perdu contre tigran petrossian donc
c'est clairement la partie a visé ici
côté côté arménien et jefferies xiong si
j'ouvrais petrosen cas un gros
spécialistes un de ses pires qui paraît
toujours dans le dur mais il défend bien
lu l'article et prend b2 quand qui a été
en c3 je sais pas quelle partie sa part
dans le chatt peu importe il a raté qui
les prend b2 ça devait tisser de zawiyah
et qui prend b2 exactement exactement om
et ça c'est énorme raté de fabiano
qu'est-ce qui l'a pas vu qu'il y prendre
ouais mais qui prend des cinq d'accord
donc c'est le coup mais qui avait prend
des cinq tours prend b2 à hilla duzert
ça c'était pas top
peut-être
étonnant quand même ce que ça t'ouvre le
fou hein c'est pas possible qu'ils aient
pas vues cac et prend b2 quand même moi
j'ai raté parce qu'on regarde les
parties on passe d'une partie à l'autre
mais cavaliers prend b2 c'est un gros
coup de la position quand même c'est
étonnant ce étonnant c'est vrai que s'il
en méforme comme ça
c'est vrai que s'il en méforme comme ça
revêtu un peu abasourdi en fait par le
raté de fabiano est en train de me
tourner le truc dans la tête parce que
tout à l'heure vraiment le kg 5 et prend
aussi s'il était quand même assez
logique à hirak le cac et prend b2 qui
est assez facile
cependant il a une bonne position quand
même hein il a vissé le pion de trois
breaks peut-être pas mieux mais ça doit
aller là petit à petit ça doit aller
petit à petit qu'est qui va revenir en
c5 et la tour en c3 mais le pion m6 est
bien placé il empêche les cavaliers 5
carélie g5 et il n'y a pas de deuxième
case pour le cavalier blanc et si les
blancs viennent apprendre en c4 on
prendra du pion des et on ouvrira le fou
le long de la longue diagonale break et
prend b2 j'aurais vu oui ça oui avait
cru à 66 ça c'est sûr que j'aurais vu et
ça doit ni sow le combat continue
j'ai envie de dire mais ça doit ni qui
attaque un il y va c'est vraiment très
chaud de partout au québec a et b 3 chez
hachémi qui est là voilà c'est bouillant
aussi un j'aime bien les blancs parce
que je vois deux colonnes ouverte
je vois un cavalier en b3 qui attaquent
le pion à 5 après les piètres ces
pollutions que joue le moins bien mais
aussi par l'opposition que joue mal mais
je sens un avantage blanchevoy russie
cavaliers un qui a eu trois qui haïssez
4 qui arrive je préfère les blancs après
pascal elbé 3 j'adore en vrai ce qu'il
attaque à cinq qui contrôlent ces 5
ça doit ni qui envoie tout prem's et que
s'y prend f4 il va donner la case de 5
on va voir et là c'est la partie ah ça
j'adore la sq est en train de faire part
à mme il a filé un pion à la dame mais
il s'est fait le duo de pion aux 5 f 5
et il veut d'alger trois fois 6
rafou b2 rf 6e 6 ces shows c'est
vraiment très chaude par tous les gars
mais à salah est plutôt en faveur de
l'arménie donc attendez on va résumer ça
c'est cool pour l'arménie
petrosyan xiong c'est plutôt cool pour
les américains mais pas sûr que ça aille
au bout sarah non ses pions de plus pour
fabiano c'est cool pour les américains
et ce au delà semble depuis deux salles
en mieux pour les américains donc on va
dire qu'on serait sur un scénario les
américains gagnent de 1 ici et encore et
encore j'ai peut-être été sympa avec par
am sure d'alger troyat dame prend f1
match oui mais bon par on parle d' idées
ici ok on commence par four b2 ont fait
dame j'ai trois caméras
peu importe on n'est pas là pour
commenter du coup par coup on parle on
parle idf ou p2 qui est là et ces deux
dames g3 qui prend un f6 g6 d'alger ça
il y aura la prise ici encore mais ok
c'est chaud
ces chauffeurs en vrai sens et peut-être
plutôt sur un scénario 2 ouais on va
dire 2 1 quand même pourquoi pas les
américains cependant là que côté caruana
il va mettre cavalier e 4 et on pourra
jamais prendre ce que si on fait est
fait à quoi que peut peut-être essayer
de jouer blocus sur trois après mais
faire le blocus sur gaza voire il peut
peut-être la tenir à possibilité de
tenir s'il échange des tourelles doit
être nul on va partir sur une nulle de
ike
on va espérer une nulle de petrossian
même si c'est peut-être en train de même
bien se goupiller pour les noirs bon bah
on va partir sur deux nuls ici on va
partir sur une victoire deux sauts et là
j'en sais rien donc on va partir sur un
avantage américain
mais la dame c'est un rouage de dame
prend b2 est ce que la partie n'est pas
en train de tourner ce que le pion b il
est quand même très proche de dames et
il va attaquer f2 au passage avec des
idées si on prend un air de yap fois ci
sous f 4 1 c'est matt tout de suite
cavaliers h5 et seimat attend pourquoi
pourquoi y ait un ban aussi automatique
ludwig sur rue et h rue de 6,2 seagraves
franchement ça mérite pas un banal ban
des flatteries ce qui se passe après
peut-être des antécédents ou quoi mais
ça me paraît un peu rapide comme band f
soupe c'est quelqu'un qui l'est les
jours précédents et peut-être dit des
choses intéressantes dans le chat c'est
parti un peu un peu fort quand même
écrit juste calme-toi chlamydia a faim
après peut-être un rip sur le clic mais
ça me paraît ça me paraît quand même
très sévère
je vais je vais des bagnes pour le
moment entre alger des vannes pour le
moment mais non là moi c'est quand même
un peu j'ai débarqué musique c'est quand
même un peu un peu c'est vers quoi on
peut important pas se perdre sur le
match et une proposition nul à l'est où
la proposition de nul assez de nouveaux
renac mars est terrible il est déjà
gamin il propose des nuls à toutes les
parties n'ont pu tuer h juste web ont
ils trop là un peu de temps en temps
quoi mais là il n'y avait pas non plus
en plus je pense tu dois être assez bon
échecs n'ont eu et pour la peine en fait
je pense c'est quelqu'un qui joue assez
bien et cantiques en titre hall pas pour
la peine il a assez pertinents je pense
il doit être au moins 2002 à mon avis
après peut-être que je me trompe mais
maintenant je pense juste qu'il a peur
en vrai je pense si les pleutres ils
proposent trop de nuls quand même à
toutes les parties ça on va voir je
pense que cette position était tellement
le bordel c'est dur de juger là le match
c'est hyper chaud parce que parent ami
si fou des quatre vents le fou est
attaqué on peut admettre tout des
caprices des quatre il peut prendre à 6
il peut à partir pour les rues d'alger 3
il peut alors du tout inquiet moi je
prends les blancs ici on refait on
refait notre tour des stades
ici je ne me prononce pas mais les noirs
sont plus ou moins bien c'est sûr le
pion b est trop fort car il va l'arrêter
avec b2 qui a aidé de il contrôle la
case bien mais c'est hyper chaud donc
chaud chaud avantages clairs et nets
noir mais sûrement nul et renac contre
sow il va passer un mauvais bien mauvais
moment le gamin carrier qui sera une
verser 5 il va passer un très mauvais
moment c'est les blancs qui ont les
poussées inquiète même en f4 encore plus
fort il risque de se faire transpercer
par un cahier prend des 5 1 jour et s'il
enlève la tour y aura tout reprend ses 6
il va probablement
ben behe 8 ici il va se faire sacrifier
ans et cissé va la perdre il aurait dû
faire plus attention et c'est peut-être
de mettre un quart ayant et fils bon
donc on va dire victoire sow part à mme
chow a et qui tient mais maintenant
c'est xiang petrossian qui est
passionnant est ce que fout b4 et un
coup sûr madame b hui 3g cette dame 5
perpétuelle ouais donc ça doit être nul
ça a fait un nul petrossian nul ait des
fêtes renac et ça va tout jouer ici donc
on va rester sur cette partie les gars
avec par am qui a une attaque mais du
coup on sait pas quels lots de iwate
param param qui a une partie père
importante il est pas vraiment mieux
ou peut-être qu'il est mieux j'en sais
rien je n'arrive pas je n'arrive pas à
évaluer non il doit être un peu mieux
mais il doit pas être gagnant mais la
question c'est ce qui va la tenir ou pas
est ce qui va la gagner ou pas mais je
pense que si la gagne pas assez game
donc il va faire tout re 1,6 ont fait
tour à 20 il défend comment alors 10 10
tours 6 dames g53 dans des huit damage
six des huit thèmes et schwyz wade doit
pouvoir défendre en fait c'est moi aussi
je suis hyper optimiste dans ce genre de
position ne faut pas que je me fasse
trop confiance il fait dame g5 direct
sur damas
à dammaj six dames g7 au relais ce que
tu pars pour moi je suis tour g8 où tu
pars pour dams et cinq dames b4 dame
baies vitrées dame est fixé plus fort
est donc là on imagine
moi j'imagine un tour assez un ici
puisque dame pro saint curé d'ars âge
this way
la dame qui doit repartir à esquiver en
b 4 à 3 ou avait fui direct ça je sais
pas mais l'at on prend ces sept avec
peut-être des tours 7
avec qui des tours 7
ah oui et tours 7 ton procès d'un match
6 dames g7 mattila raté il a raté l'idée
de marloux entoure cette série perfore
sacrifice de deux blocus quoi de
d'obstruction saint christ d'obstruction
tour s'est tu sur ton à cette dame hcc
games tour 7 s'est finie direct et
l'ordi là non il annonce +5 légal ordi
surtout recettes
j'avais vu le piège de marloux il peut
pas le rater il peut pas le rater
dames ck oui mais ok tu attaquer mais
juste un petit coup de tours amy adams
et 8 encore ah non non il ya encore des
défenses ah oui mais ya ton premier set
qui arrive pardon j'avais rien vu j'ai
senti que ça gagner mais ça gagne pour
par amsa a perdu pour ça doit ni et ça
ça se voyait qu'il allait la perdre
maintenant il faut espérer que avec la
tiennent bon et de l'autre côté c'est le
feu oh là là les parties de dengue là
o les parties de dengue faut que faut
qu'on ait la tienne c'est quand même une
sacrée partie de merde car mike ce qu'il
a filé le cavalier prend b2 il a deux
pions moins maintenant mais il fait un
blocus sur cases noires et la
proposition nul ok ça a fait nul côté
jeffrey petrossian il faut qu'ils la
tienne mais autant vous dire elle est
dure à tenir
il va pas la tenir il ya roi c5 qui
rentre il va pas la tenir à une bouffé
un peu la feuille mike bray par amis
bien joué on sentait que ça se passait
2000 gazon est mauvais ce soir
fabiano papa pas impérial tactiquement
mais tellement fort assez sèchement ça à
perdre côté à côté avec le fou qui
rendent cet outil rendent c'est horrible
c'est terrible pion qui va partir en d4
ouais c'est mauvais ces mauvaises café
avec ce soir enfin cette partie à quoi
il a un demi point
ils bouffent le match
l'aïe avait roi c5 javel ordi avec idée
des kakis et prend des quatre tours 3 et
c'est plus gagnant fabiano fabiano
fabiano qui a déconné là les amis de
l'attak de batte de marloux oulalalala
les gars fabiano qui s'est mis le feu
tous rêvent sept ans leur dit qu'ils
annoncent gagnon roi des six trois des
six qui sait si ce tour c'est cette matt
aut c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
gagnant pour le joueur aux médias olala
caruana caruana est minuscule les amis
auj les minuscules ce soit il va
peut-être tenir une nulle quand même
quand il est incroyable caruana
qu'est-ce qui rate mais qu'est ce qu'ils
ratent et la caisse qui ferrique
pourquoi il n'a pas pris le pion à vent
et un sac choc des deux côtés il aurait
eu tourner cet échec s'il avait pris
avant et tout reprend des quatre au nom
au nom ike
il a contre eux de chauds qu'il va faire
ok vas faire tour 17 pouces et de rouaf
6 3 bougez tour des quatre héros apprend
g6 mais il a il a un peu de show quand
même parce qu'il a surtout bien il a
tout reprend à 4 d2 et tour des quatre
il est chaud qui la choque
il prend g6 à une menace 2.95 donc il
faut il va refaire wave si si si et
c'est zoug et on prend 1,4 maintenant on
la gagne mais non non prend à quatre
petits points 4 prend à 4 qui tu fais
mais north bay prend pas 4 il prend pas
4 il le voit pas et c'est plus gagnant
mais comment il voit pas ça il agit
ok et maintenant c'est plus gagnant il
va peut-être la perdre en réalité il
ajuste choc
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable mais
attendez maintenant faut faire flamber 3
c'est chaud c'est chaud les gars assez
chaud tout reprend f5 et jouable
maintenant sur des deux il ya toujours
cinq échecs et non sur des deux miroirs
france et de pardon c'est peut-être de
nouveaux gagnants
c'est bouillant les gars il va envoyer
le plus bref ça à mes deux pions et va
pas aller au bout assez nul quand même
hall est chaude de malades dans la game
et ça c'est nul
parce que fc3f si c'est la tour peut pas
repartir
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a raté tout
reprend 1,4 des deux est tourné autour
des quatre équipes
la nul n'y a pas de choix qu'est ce
qu'ils ont raté les deux il va devoir
faire tour ses huit tours français 2
essais nul n'y a rien à faire
et là c'est vraiment la pression rien
d'autre c'est incroyable c'est que la
pression il peut pas là
on va faire tout reprendre et 3 allée
tombe pas à gros te mets pas de cesse
c'est incroyable il a raté le truc tout
reprend à 4 c'était juste fini c'est ici
en fait au lieu de tourbe et 4 juste on
reprend à 4 c'est fini lui immédiatement
ces abandons direct c'est la même partie
que la position de tout à l'heure sauf
que tu aurais eu le pion à la fin qui va
à dame et sur des deux juste tour des
quatre non non c'est pas un mythe clic
parce qu'en fait s'il avait mis ce clic
ou alors c'est m'expliquer
parce qu'après tourbe et quatre pouces
et oui mais il aurait pu faire déjà la
roi au sein non mais il a raté deux fois
en fait ce que la re 5 c soupçonne ans
il a déjà trois quatre donc non non
c'est pas missclick ya vrai dire il y
avait trois points f5 aussi parce que
sur des 2 3 ou 5 ya pas d un dame donc
en réalité il a il ajustera telle idée
parce qu'il a raté trois points f5 aussi
donc du coup en fait sur re5 roi l'ata
aussi roi pro f 5 sites avaient fait un
mix clic c'est juste le stress il a
juste raté toute l'idée qui a pas de
médias pas de d2 des impasses que le
fouet pas en c2 c'est la main qui
tremble mais s'il te plaît à robin side
un petit peu de un petit peu de tenue
dans le tchat
mais ouais c'est tremblote mais caruana
énorme énorme choc aux siens parce que
tourbe et 6,6 il repart avec le roi il
fait juste roi ses cinq tours prend un
f6 des quatre échecs c'est fini tout de
suite qu'elle prend des quatre tours 3
ces abandons direct gagne aucun radio
prochain bon il sur wade 2e tour des 3
ouais ouais c'est choc sous la pression
terrifiant ça arrive un de la part des
deux joueurs d'ailleurs deux gros raté
de la part des deux joueurs
après les pas en confiance il a un demi
sur deux il est gagnant contre caruana
il vient de passer par une position
complètement foutu et il craque ça
arrive
ces clauses il était ces tours prend 1,4
c tres ccc samassa m'arrive aussi un
quand vous dites parfois ouais mais tu
as raté si tu as raté sa feinte la sq il
a raté c'est comme quand le rader ma
tendance est évident enfin quand on
prend 1,4 tu le vois tempo auront à
prendre cinq buts tempo c'était des
coups très très très facile c'est que la
pression
ces choses 6 partout c'est très chaud
voilà il a raté à 4 f 5 il a raté deux
coups d'affilée
il a mis la rate et l'idée pourrait en
fait tout cas c'est un beau match il
faut reconnaître ce soir c'est un beau
match c'est une très très belle finale
et donc vous êtes pas trompés un public
s'est pas trompé c'est un peu dommage
les matches d'avant n'est pas été à la
hauteur avec des joueurs trop attentiste
et sap a été terrible bien qu'en cas
d'égalité ça j'expliquerai mais les
quatre joueurs rejouant oublie de
cendres non à les matchs sont bien
placés les matchs sont bien qu'ils
mènent actuellement finale est à 6
partout il ya le score et criaient
ohhhhh normalement je vérifier oui aux
deux sur yahia le score arménien à 6
saint louis 6 par la serbe au max un
beau match on ne s'y est pas trompé les
amis
ne s'y est pas trompé ça se joue en
cognant le premier à huit et demi donc
là ça va être la dernière ronde en cas
de 8,8
il va y avoir un tie-break qu'on se
suivra ensemble le format en cas
d'égalité en faveur des arméniens je
suis pas d'accord avec toi british parce
qu'en fait ça va jouer quatre contre
quatre en cas de nul et 2 sont éliminés
en cas de victoire à bath celui qui perd
est éliminé mais des frictions en fait
il peut déjà faire très mal à toute
l'équipe adverse
le problème des arméniens eagles en
réalité c'est qu'ils ont que deux
joueurs qui peuvent vraiment faire mal
c'est haïk et maxou de loup et à et
angres occasion saut et dominguez
peuvent sortir toute leur équipe donc
ils ont trois joueurs qui peuvent tous
les sortir mais j'espère voir un mois
j'espère voir un match nul très
clairement ouais les honneurs qui fait
un mauvais match on est bien d'accord
tous dominguez qui fait un mauvais match
ça arrive un dominguez et fabiano en
fait qui font un mauvais match mais les
autres font font leur match en mai 2000
gaz et fabiano font leur match tout cas
c'est une belle finale
c'est il faut reconnaître qu'en quand ce
camp c'est pas bien et quand c'est relou
on le reconnaît quand c'est bien on le
reconnaît aussi il faut être fair play
dans les deux sens et là c'est vrai que
c'est un match très très sympa
très fort ce soir mais non mais fabiano
l'a franchement robin side là autant
autant la performance générale des
arméniens voilà je peux largement
comprendre qu'ils aient des doutes
autant ce soir
t'as pas les deux chocs
de caruana qui sont là en fait il est
gagnant deux fois il ya un point et demi
de plus c'est à cet ennemi il ya cet été
2004 et demi s'il ya pas les deux chocs
de karwan high k vraiment cet ennemi
quatre et demi pour pour saint louis et
c'est quasiment fini en fait ils font un
sur quatre et c'est gagné
la partie à rebondissements est vraiment
qu'à raqqa juana les deux trucs qu'il a
en fait c'est qu'ils tuent les deux
games et c'est fini ça abandon là dans
l'outil férois c5 sa abandon et comme
ici fait le carré les g5 et prend aussi
sa bande ont donc là non vraiment ricard
wana dans une forme juste normal le
match est déjà plié
fabio très loin d'être la pièce
maîtresse de l'équipe
ouais tout à fait on peut en voir la fin
de la partie ii soa
pourquoi pas un bon s'est arrêté là et
je vous avais dit qu'il y aurait un tour
prend ses 6 et c'est exactement ça s'est
passé il ya tout qui tombe en vrai c'est
juste la position de tombes la position
de tombes simplement cajon apparemment
donc la maintenance et les échiquiers il
se joue entre le 2 juin concluant le 2
contre le 2 donc les deux hommes en
forme tigran et wesley qui vont
s'affronter les deux hommes en méforme
dominguez et avec qui vont s'affronter
aussi ma glouglou contre caruana
avantage de forme a par am
mais mon fabiano quand même en face et
jefferies xiong contre ça doit ni
sadoine il faut lui mettre la tête au
fond
on va voir ça va être extrêmement tendue
ça va être extrêmement tendue évidemment
saint-louis favori mais mais mais tout
peut arriver les gars dans une fin de
match qui va être accrochés et beaucoup
de retournements de situation et dans
les partis c'est on a en a qu'on a pu
penser dans la deuxième on notamment y
avait il ya débat qui qui pensaient que
ça ferait aussi très cher il menait deux
et demi heure et demie saint louis ça
semblait pouvoir faire très cher côté
côté américain il pensait pour apprendre
un litre de trois points a vraiment
pensé qu'ils gagnent et gagneraient au
moins trois donc ils ont eu quatre
points d'avance et finalement finalement
eu le petit craquage les arméniens qui
sont revenus et là encore dans cette
ronde où les houles et où les américains
semblaient pouvoir faire les cas ils se
font remonter notamment à cause de
fabiano qui a craqué encore une fois
donc le match est serré
c'est pas un match auquel s'attendaient
les américains faut aussi le voir les
américains pensaient pouvoir contrôler
le match prendre le lead assez
rapidement et amener peut-être un plus
de +3 la victoire tranquillement dans
les rondes 3,4 ils sont maintenant dans
un combat de rue à égalité ou le stress
et la pression va jouer son rôle avec
des hommes comme wesley so caruana
dominguez tu peux te dire qu'ils sont
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'être sous
pression mais c'est par équipes
ça peut être différent et tu étais
peut-être pas dans le maïs est dans
l'état d'esprit avant avant le match de
se retrouver dans un truc serré comme ça
les arméniens sont forcément heureux
d'arriver à ce score là à ce moment là
donc c'est difficile à dire après
j'imagine que dans les gros les moments
difficiles comme ça les grands joueurs
n'en ressorte que plus fort mais rien
n'est sûr rien n'est sûr on va voir
on va voir ça va reprendre à 21h
ça va reprendre à 21h et ça va être très
intéressant les gars de savoir qui
l'emportent là c'est vrai que ça va se
jouer à rien là ça va vraiment se jouer
à un rien ouais les pauses sont un peu
longues je suis d'accord avec toi et omg
aux accès même pas moi j'aurais fait un
truc un poil différent
j'aurais fait jouer les joueurs n'est
qu'à danser un peu plus courte en 5 + 0
en 3 + 2 ou en 5 plus de monde à voir ça
après mais en fait je l'aurais fait
jouer à de manière consécutive en fait
partie 1 partie 2 parties trois parties
4 et j'aurais enchaîné comme ça les
games pour avoir un truc plus dynamique
avec peut-être une pause à la mi temps
de dix minutes mais avec une seule pause
en fait pendant tout le match et du coup
en fait tu aurais tu aurais vu partie 1
partie 2 parties trois parties quatre
parties cinq partis six parties cette
partie huit partis neuf partis disent
partisans ce parti 12 parties 13 14 15
16 quoi donc ça te fait 16 parties de de
dix minutes un peu moins huit minutes ça
te fait en gros deux grosses heures de
match ça te fait à peu près le même
temps mais je trouve que c'est plus
dynamique
je trouve
victoire dallas philippe aujourd'hui qui
est bien parti dans la dernière dans la
dernière ascension il a pris il a pris 6
7 secondes et les autres après qu'ils se
sont regardés mais magnifique victoire
elle est très très vite
elle a fait un super jump eux à la fin
pour pour terminer l'ascension est le
groupe derrière après que c'est pas du
tout entendu bref en art en sueur
monarque était sûrement le plus fort
intrinsèquement mais il avait trop la
pancarte supposé trop fort
allez on va repartir caruana contre
parham carnet avec les blancs une petite
espagnole où ça c'est le premier premier
échiquier donc ils s'affrontent espagnol
classique
sebastian a il repart dans la berlinoise
qui n'avait pas trop réussi contre renac
renac et joue un plan avec à 5 à 4
rapide
tigran petrossian a qui joue son petit
réty contre wesley
mais est ce assez pénible j'ai même
revue des vieilles parties de guy
hellers et tous et c'est vraiment
pénible ce truc alors dit préfère
toujours les noirs mais en réalité c'est
pas simple à jouer d'autant plus en
rapide et ronak qui se refait visé dans
le qui se refait visé dans dans la time
à 9 rebonds dans les ouvertures les
américains ont semblé plutôt prendre le
dessus généralement on va voir ce qui se
passe dans cette dernière deux dernières
parties donc là le la sarre et site de
la théorie il n'ya pas fou pranger 4 à
cause de tour des quatre ans les gars
titan enfilade donc le fou qui va venir
en os 6
il faudra faire garde de passements des
f4 f5 prenait a convenu dans trois deux
un vrai rhône à caen sur alors voir
partir sur l'échiquier numéro 1 donc il
a fait le sais tape à la bombe à qui
nous a parlé avec fougue et cette part
âme et pour jouer ces six alex il suit
les idées de baky après d'ailleurs par
am qui est un joueur étranger dans
l'équipe d'arménie est un joueur iranien
et savait que l'iran est ce que l'iran a
une frontière physique avec l'arménie je
ne pense pas mais c'est vraiment pas
loin
c'est vraiment pas loin du tout vrai
qu'ils ont une équipe quand même assez
accueilla que rona qu'en réalité qui est
qu'il ya un joueur un peu un peu plus
éloignés géographiquement très petit
temps ils ont une toute petite frontière
je pensais que c'était c'était dans le
domaine du possible donc sur le joueur
qui sont qui sont qui sont proches c'est
comme si on avait un joueur italien dans
l'équipe ou quoi arméniens mais mais
géographiquement très proche
tongs en bas on va faire un petit résumé
on va on va on va se faire les petits
résumés donc berlinoise échiquier numéro
2 berlinoise position où le joueur
arménien hak et plutôt sorti
correctement de l'ouverture échiquier
numéro 1 fabiano contre parham espagnol
ça a eu l'air d'être assez théorique
pendant un moment et ça l'est peut-être
encore position tendu il n'y a pas
d'écart qui est fait échiquier numéro 3
wesley so contre tigran bon là
l'ordinateur vous dira toujours que les
noirs sont mieux où il aime bien les
noirs mais c'est hyper chaud parce qu'il
peut y avoir des sacrifices et une
attaque puissante sur le roi franchement
contre un joueur qui joue tout le temps
ça comme tigran en rapide c'est hyper
dangereux
il peut envoyer des quadrillages de
cavaliers h 6 kg 4 le retour et c'est
très dangereux pour wesley c'est très
chaud et la partie qui nous inquiétait
donc c'est celle ci c'est celle de sa
doit ni contre jefferies ouais donc il
n'a pas tenté de prendre l'aventage du
tout avec les blancs et il se prend même
un centre côté noir
donc là encore là je dirais que j'ai
free est plutôt bien sorti donc pour le
moment quatrième échiquier plutôt en
faveur des américains face à un renard
qu'en plus ce qui peut être un peu dans
le dur il a un demi sur trois contre
trois monstres mais quand même ça fait
mal de d'enchaîner les défaites et sur
les trois autres échiquiers j'irai
personne n'a fait l'écart mais l'écart
pourrait venir de petrossian quand même
ça peut ça peut être
très tendu pour moi c'est on va voir
paramés ce qu' il se débrouille bien
dans son espagne en tout cas ça joue
vite il a mis la tour ans et 4 ans et 4
b france et 4 ça créerait des échanges
la tour prend prises qui avait b6 qui
essaient 4 il joue vite il a eu il a
l'air d'être sûr de ce qui fait
attention quand même il ya beaucoup d
espaces allaient droit mais il faut
ensuite règne en maître sur des 6 ch 6
dax il va peut-être y avoir foule prend
prises et peut-être un redéploiement du
cavalier par là bas ils laissent le fou
de cases noires avec l'idée de reprendre
avec la dame sûrement et de se dire
qu'il aura jamais de fou qui revient là
parce que le roi va se faire attaquer
intéressant petrosyan a fait cavalier
gh2 alors il veut g4 g5
mais ça c'est toujours tendu à jouer il
va peut-être se prend à 9,6 je sais pas
il envoie tout sur le roi il a
l'habitude
dalé pour pour mike quand même faut pas
se prendre un truc car il est des cats
et le pion f avance mais je dirais que
ça plutôt une tête d'un truc qui va plus
ou moins bien sûr mieux pour les non
j'ai l'impression que les américains
sont quand même en train de prendre le
dessus
je comprends pas vraiment où les où les
arméniens peuvent être mieux par contre
je vois des petits avantages pour les
américains qui se dessine de partout
c'est ainsi les eagles veulent gagner
fonction des animaux jeu ouais j'ai peur
qu'ils payent leur quatrième échiquier
un peu faible comme je lisais un peu
plus haut dans le chat c'est vrai que il
aurait la même équipe avec aronian à la
place de saad oignies ce serait quand
même pas la même
ça quand même pas la même gueule mais
sans vouloir manquer de respect aux
jeunes ça doit ni qui sera peut-être un
jour un joueur du top mondial
mais bon entre aronian qui est top 10
mondial depuis plus d'une décennie et on
peut être qu'il y ait plus exactement
maintenant mais qui est un qui est un
membre du top mondial depuis depuis
maintenant très longtemps et ça doit ni
cas que 14 15 piges il ya quand même un
montre il ya quand même un monde
elle va mettre le cavalier ranger 4
prendre h6 ça envoie de partout fabiano
ici qui doit pouvoir peut-être
contourner les pièces noires et ramener
le carélien ans et 6
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
proposition nul on va tout de suite allé
au cc ronak cl famose aux propositions
nul de renac non mais ça m'a
piètre qu'à son âge il fasse déjà ça ça
m'inquiète
qu'à son âge il fasse déjà ça serve
qu'il est déjà dans le maïs est dans
l'état d'esprit je fais des petites nul
à 15 ans ces problématiques
donc il est pas mieux de soissons mais
j'ai free qui a peut-être intérêt à
accepter un derby armand ça peut se
jouer sur la tacc de tigre had mais on a
quand même l'impression que sow est en
train de très bien la gérer
je conte
voir faire nul mais il veut tout en fait
c'est psychologique car les gars s'est
il fait ici proposent pas nul pour
s'amuser un seuil psychologique avec
sauce semble dominer ici dans un
complexe et pacy gré mais généralement
les complexes comme ça quand il commande
jeunes ça fait qu'empirer rien en gros
je vois où les je vois où les américains
peuvent mettre des points ça peut être
ici contre parham petite domination
pions b5 attaqué cavalli qui jaillit ans
et 6 on voit que les pièces blanches
doit être supérieure aux pièces noires
cavaliers c6 l'échangé le tour et le
pion b5 en l'air cahier ces deux
cavaliers à 3 donc le carrier qui part à
la triple pression sur le pion et le
carélien c6 monstrueux donc on a on a
une position de rêve pour les blancs
possibles
petrossian contre sow web on paye là
elle va falloir faire l'exploit en fait
c'est au victoire obligatoire pour les
arméniens mais sow c'est quand même un
gros défenseur mais qui sait ça doit ni
il a déjà proposé là nul et je pense que
nul serait un bon résultat pour lui dans
tous les cas et il ya cette position-là
de la berlinoise dont je suis pas
spécialiste on n'a pas trop parlé mais
on a l'impression que hay que commence à
se faire presser parce
peu pressé j'ai pas envie d recommence
mais voilà il était un peu moins bien
depuis le début de l'ouverture il reste
un peu moins bien mais il peut la tenir
donc voilà le résumé du match cette
partie petrossian sow pourrait peut-être
la partie décisive parce que ça peut
gagner d'un côté ou de l'autre
petrossian qui a deux ennemis alors là
est ce qu on peut s que ghg h cavaliers
g5 fou prend bessette est une option
tafer fou prendront un intermédiaire
mais en gros est ce que ça ça peut être
en faveur des blancs pour devenir
propriétaire des cases blanches ail à 2
qui tombe à la fin donc j'ai envie de
dire la réponse est répondu bien assez
tôt mais commencer par g h ça donne
quand même envie dans tous les cas j'ai
h et peut-être d'un f4 à leur tour
recettes pour défendre s'il est revenu
là et cavaliers d2 avec l'idée sur fou
prend roi prend cavalia 2 de faire
cavalier ou quatre cahiers français car
il ya six bouffe f6 bouffe f 6 3 je suis
dans le cadre d'un match 7 matches haye
adam des cinq encore mais le quart eli
contrôle mais bon vous m'avez compris je
moi je montre une idée après geagea jdam
f4 c'est la partie moi je montre une
idée après c'est la partie qui se
déroule un séchaud quand même on va
retourner voir fabiano
par contre là c'est très très chaud en
faveur des américains
cavalier ans et si c'est vraiment le cas
d'alliance et 6 on voit on voit la clé
que fabiano est beaucoup mieux
parham dans le dur ça doit ni sa échange
de fou il veut aller chercher ça nul qui
devraient pouvoir obtenir et ça nous
laisse
ça nous laisse ike les américains sont
sont devant la les américains sont
devant clairement pas ce que la pression
côté côté côté dominguez ya pression et
l'arrivée le caïd et de dont je vous
parlais il ya pression côté dominguez ya
pression côté à fabiano et quand je dis
pression ces deux grosses pressions il
ya partie incertaine ici et ça joue pour
la nulle de l'autre côté
donc en gros il ya deux grosses
pressions une petite pression et un truc
chaud les américains sont loin devant
mais après caruana depuis tout à l'heure
et chaude toxiques à roanne en route
choqué que ça refait nul
bah du coup c'est très très chaud mais
il va falloir un chop côtes américains
pour que les arméniens puisse faire
quelque chose il n'a pas fait qu'il y
ait des deux il a fait tour 1 il va
faire qui a aidé de maintenant ça va
être tendu
ouais très difficile les gars de savoir
ce qui va se passer mais les américains
sans mouvement devant je tourne un peu
sur les sur les échiquiers fabiano la
pression est dingue
il a toutes les pièces bien placé et
noir sont un peu reclus à attendre un
petit grain
j 1 cm x games inc à la main il file la
kalach mellal pion à super forme
non la cesse et c'est trop dur là on
voit on voit plus après un miracle de sa
doit ni sade rien un scénario où il a
gagné
c'est le scénario réussi à faire ces
trois b 4 mais normalement il n'ya pas
un seul monde où il le fait mais un
scénario où il ferait un truc comme ça
mais même là on n'y arrive pas mais lui
réussir et non mais en fait c'est
impossible
j'essaye de trouver un scénario où il a
gagné il n'y a que des scénarios il peut
perdre et jefferies doit pas là doit pas
la force et ici c'est bien de partout la
position de ike de toute façon il est
moins bien parce que à bas il fera
jamais de pompe à sallèles dames les
blancs vont en faire un allèle roi et
c'est un vrai avantage un roi pour un f6
va peut-être faire des fouilles fca tout
détourage 5 donc position difficile
comme j'ai fabiano pocho qu il n'est pas
forcément en confiance et son on voit
pas pourquoi ils perdraient spécialement
non plus parce que son pion à a3 vaut
bien une qualité donc pour le moment
tous les feux sont au vert pour l'équipe
de saint louis
maintenant quand il s'agit de mettre les
poings dans des moments décisifs parfois
parfois parfois ça peut ça peut ça peut
craquer parfois ça peut craquer dame f8
là il veut clairement partir avec sa
tour et plus filer la caboche
ouais c c c est difficile toujours rien
de moins côté parade messapresse de plus
en plus
arnaque qui tente le plan pour la gagner
mais bon il va se prendre un des quatre
avants amédée cas ce que peut-être b4
quand même et envoyer le pion à web ont
alors bk tu auras aussi tour c4 et ouais
quoique renac qui envoie du conte
renault déjà il va sûrement pas la
perdre au moins ici il joue quand même
il joue quand même le contre non
rami fabi ils pressent toujours notre
ami avec sous pression et on va rester
un peu sur tigran qui s'est pas décidé
s'il allait prendre la qualité aussi
allait commencer par cahiers des six ça
sent le 11 606 ça va être dur hein parce
qu'il ya que 4 points à m mais pour moi
ça sent le 8 et demi cet ennemi alors là
il laisse un coup comme f si ceux-ci il
veut tour g1 pour moi ça sent le 8 et
demi cet ennemi en faveur des américains
qui seraient des beaux vainqueurs de la
compétition avec ceux qui ont la plus
forte équipe sur le papier ils ont ils
ont ils ont tout simplement trois trois
des quatre meilleurs joueurs américains
à lormont que hikaru est en 4e il aligne
des frictions qui dans cette cadence
doit être le numéro 5 donc ils ont 2 le
numéro 2 3 4 et 5 américain de la
cadence il leur manque que qui carreau
mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont la grosse
équipe allait y prend f6 vous prend et
c'est ce que je disais il a laissé le
pion poussé je ne vois même pas pourquoi
les les noirs seraient pas mieux ici
avec leurs pions à 3 non j'ai
l'impression que ça craque complètement
la côté arménien fabiano qui reste bien
en gestion rona qui la gagnera pas
normalement celle là fait on se demande
même plus il va réussir à faire annuler
et ike qui en souffrance mais qui peut
la tenir ils se chargent du contre je
mais oui en fait les arméniens ils sont
en souffrance vraiment partout
plus tôt ça aurait pu prendre la qualité
sacrifiée il avait plein d'options un
petrossian mais il sent il semble que le
pion à 3 soit trop fort non il ya juste
un pion de plus ce temps là c'est en
train de tout est en train de tourner
aux côtés américains faut pas que faut
pas se regarder maintenant côtes
américains faut pas faire comme les
quatre les cinq mêmes derrière
alaphilippe tout à l'heure qui sont un
petit peu regardés dans le blanc des
yeux et y en a aucun qui a voulu
vraiment collaborer pour pour attraper
le coureur français là c'est un peu la
même chose aux échecs si tu commences à
regarder les autres positions tu dis ils
sont tous gagnants et je veux pas
prendre la responsabilité de la gagner
tu peux rater tu peux rater la gagne ça
s'est déjà vu par équipes
tu vois que tout le monde est gagnant du
bon lotis les gagnants je vais pas trop
là risque est à tout le monde qui se dit
çà et au final la personne qui gagne et
on a même parfois qui se finissent par
perdre en voulant jouer de manière trop
sécurisé donc ça ça peut être le risque
pour les américains même en équipe pour
réussir être autonome tout en sachant ce
que voilà ce que les autres font mais là
comme personne n'a mis le point faut pas
se dire fabi va mettre le point on
attend fabi quoi ça ça peut être le
danger parce qu'à force d'attendre ça
peut se retourner contre toi
après c'est des joueurs expérimentés qui
doivent qui doivent savoir c'est cette
chose là mais ça ça peut ça peut être ça
peut être le risque de perdre des
tournées de rois ces deux tours b 5
ouais j'ai entendu dire aussi accueilli
car ou est un peu brouillée avec les
gars de saint louis et karaoké brouillé
avec les bras avec les gars de saint
louis et karoutchi est brouillé avec
tout le monde
ce terrible qu'est et qui va sûrement
revenir en 4 et leur tour f7 bon
continue à tourner sur les échiquiers
ike qui serre les dents serre les dents
serre les dents à équiper à leur tour et
7 pour prendre peut-être pour prendre g7
a envoyé les pions ou tout reprend ses
sept pour aller prendre les pions là bas
et que qui va essayer d'aller raser les
siens de ce côté là on peut se retrouver
dans un scénario avec deux pions passé
qui avance vite c'est difficile en là
pour pour l'équipe arménienne or la lidc
suroît sekkat il veut tourbe et quatre
tours b5 et fait un nul rona qui a l'air
de la tenir
paramés en souffrance depuis très
longtemps maintenant
mais pour le moment il n'a pas perdu sur
cavaliers prend bessin qui doit vouloir
faire dan 17 essayer de faire des cayes
c3 et faire tourner la game non il a il
est complètement foutu mais bon pour le
moment il est encore dedans et 40
secondes pour fabiano
en fait ils attaquent même pas le
cavalier ouais non c'est c'est c'est dur
de partout wesley so wesley so
l'ordinateur annonce +6 pour petrossian
hausse est terrible aux irois je suis de
fous j'ai trois ans c'est terrible oh
c'est terrible adorent didonne tour m6
et c'est fini et oui tout rêve si c'est
fini cavaliers fils d'un médecin que
lecavalier qui tombe au c'est peut-être
là que c'est en train de tourner de
nouveau côté côte arméniens sont voyez
pas du tout la perte fief si c'est la
même eau hyper hyper il perd la partie
c'est fini
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour wesley
tours fc est que les progressistes qui
prend f6 tour prend 2,6 il fallait faire
tout reprend et il se trouve que ça
c'est gagnant au c'est incroyable assez
incroyable sow qui craque
tigran qui va finir à trois et demi à
wesley qui la perd on attend d'elle ni
hao et oui ça doit ni qui a fait nul en
attendant aux usa il a pas dû s'en va
jefferies qui pouvait plus rien faire et
maintenant c'est l'arménie qui prend le
lead à ça va être aux américains de
répondre s'arrête aux américains de
répondre mais c'est les américains qui
ont quand même la main sur le match avec
avec dominguez qui met quand même une
pression depuis tout à l'heure et
surtout aux médias plus qu'une seule
seconde côté un côté famille
il n'y a plus de plan de plus les
américains qui ont donc
ok les américains qui ont le show que
les amis en arménie qui est très proche
de la victoire petrosur qu'à 1000 points
fabiano qui n'est plus gagnon fabiano
qui en difficulté et qui est en train de
coûter le match à son équipe
le fou qui va atterrir en d2 ça peut
être très vite a peut être fini en
arménie l'arménie qu'est en train de le
gagner ce match il en rit sont en train
de se gagner comme des grands le roi qui
vit à angers 7 ya plus rien la côte et
fabiano il faut la défendre maintenant
côté côté ike
ouais c'est chaud pour high que quand
même un rake qui est sous pression
mais mary que kia qui a la balle de
match entre entre les jambes un holà il
peut il peut y aller la tour qui peut
arriver en b3 la tour 1 foot c'est
incroyable retournement de situation
ils ont été forts les arméniens ce soir
non mais là il était encore en grande
difficulté ils reviennent incessamment
quant à la finale elle paraît bien nulle
via le purell 3 qui tombe on ya
pourpoint f3 il ya ton problème
3 les amis tour f 6 nuls théorique assez
facile en le match que en train d'être
pliée par par l'équipe d'arménie
elle peut même prendre peut-être avec le
tour d'ailleurs pourquoi prendre avec la
tour b est allé mettre un est allé
mettre un un père pète on est incroyable
cette finale ça va tout jouer sur parade
qui va devoir la tenir well as il ya
plus aucune chance pour dominguez un il
obligé d'arrêter les maths ou à sous
peine sous peine de perdre donc là c'est
là c'est terminé
ça va tout jouer sur fabiano parade qui
va devoir tenir la pression est là il a
une balle de projets s'élevait entre les
mains il a il a un cavalier il a un
cavalier de la protaste ligue et il va
falloir il va falloir trouver les bons
coups et pas et pas de show car ils
jouent contre le numéro deux mondial est
ce que tu fais fou prend bk dame b1 et
on adversaires bougent plus une minute
trente cinq pour repas ram qui a le
temps d'y penser
alors ça c'est pas forcément la bonne
nouvelle côté côté arménien c'est qu'il
attend de savoir qu'il a besoin de faire
nul il aurait pas de temps il pourrait
blitz est hélas il ya peut-être des
dames 3e 4 qui tombe
ouais mais là il joue il joue le père
pète fabiano en fabiano en mode suicide
voilà il y aura perpète max pour fabiano
ils y aura jamais rien de mieux la dame
qui va devenir en f3 cavaliers 4 ça sa
tournée là il y aura jamais de vic c'est
impossible de gagner ça pour pour
dominguez c maximum nul est coté fabiano
c'est en train
ça a craqué il n'y a pas de monde où il
la gagne pas il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
monde vulgaire où il fait pas au moins
nul n'y a même pas un échec qui menace
il ya juste air de chez m mais il ya la
pression de d'une victoire dans la
compétition
l'arménie qui pourrait qui pourrait
refaire la différence là il va refaire
il fait chez 5 il fait même pas échec
il continue à jouer pour gagner qu'est
ce que c'est bien joué de la part la
part de par am qui continue à jouer la
gagne et il va envoyer il va envoyer g4
ils menacent d'un f3 maintenant il va
faire hkd j'imagine tous les pions qui
sont en train d'arriver sur le pro
froide fabiano gh2 f3 g3 ça va tomber et
de l'autre côté et de l'autre côté ça
joue la gagne aussi 1 du coup côté
arménien dominguez qui essayent de la
force et est tombé 2 on y va peut-être
la perte dominguez hyper hyper le pion
qui par le pion qui risque de partir
tout reprend g2 et et le roi qui monte
oh c'est fini dans c'est pas fini c'est
pas fini à 2 il ya tout raciste pardon
c'est pas fini mais peut-être trois
bessette et à 2 c'est fini c'est fini
le pion non c'est pas fini c'est pas
fini roye b 6 3 b 5 ans et chaussées
chaud les gars c'est chaud c'est chaud
même moi je ne choque
ouais tout retour à sion n'ya pas tour
prado ya tourache deux airois airois b3
et roye b 2 c'est fini c'est fini
l'arménie qui s'imposent les amis c'est
fini il peut essayer ça y est c'est
gagné roye b de ndam en l'arménie qui va
s'imposer dans cette compétition qu'est
ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est cruel
les américains qui avaient le match en
main est ce que je vous disais ils sont
regardés dans le blanc des yeux et il
craque les parades qui gagne et par am
qui grade c'est l'écrin nada les
américains qui sont inexistants dissegna
6 ennemis dégager tous les amis c'est
une victoire de l'arménie qui explose
c'est les adversaires américains
exceptionnel exceptionnel ces arméniens
qui une nouvelle fois marche sur cette
compétition pas de bluff
ils sont là et ils ont mangé les
américains tout cru ils sont nuls
caruana dominguez sow exergue les
arméniens qui montre une nouvelle fois
que
qu'il faut compter sur sûre dans cette
prochaine si comme je vous disais je
crois que sur internet ils n'ont perdu
qu'un seul match
il gagne absolument tous les matches il
marche sur les compétitions
et là encore il bat les grands favoris
les saint louis rams bishop qui se font
marcher dessus par l'arménie qui
remporte une nouvelle fois cette
compétition deuxième victoire en trois
participations pour les arméniens ils
sont tout simplement impressionnants et
ce en l'absence un jeu le rappel de
leurs numéros 1 leeuwen aronian c'est
pour dire le niveau de cette équipe
d'arménie exceptionnel les amis victoire
exceptionnelle de l'arménie sur un score
sans appel mais vraiment les joueurs
américains qui ont eu chaud car vraiment
c'est exceptionnel exceptionnel belle
victoire à l'arménie qui l'emportent pas
les meilleures équipes de loin alors
franchement on peut dire maintenant les
choses en face qui vous avez dit qui
vous avait dit avant les demi-finales
arménie favorite de la compétition j'ai
twitté j'ai twitté quand ils ont joué
contre les bras pas de chance vous allez
perdre et je les dis avant je l'avais
dit que l'arménie était la favorite de
la compétition vous pensiez que c'était
du troll pas de chance pour vous j'avais
annoncé la victoire de l'arménie avant
qui était la grosse cote un hommage que
compte y avait pas les bookmakers gym à
nice sur dans les pays où il ya les
bookmakers c'était minimum une cote à
main mais voilà pas de bluff pas de
bluff l'arménie qui l'emportent
impérial dans ce format et qui remporte
une nouvelle promesse league
j'avais dit même si personne n'y croyait
acquis recruit kiwi khroub la prochaine
saison c'est peut-être en janvier c'est
ça reprend ce sera en janvier passé
et perdre après on rêve j'ai essayé de
suivre un peu le public mais bon j'avais
annoncé victoire de l'armée ni l'armée
ni à gagner c'est mieux que tu nous sors
ça il y a dix minutes j'ai sorti ça
avant la compétition déjà j'ai de ne
donner l'arménie avant avant que la prod
chaise que cette saison de la protège a
stick des marges avait déjà donné
l'arménie grande favorite pas de bluff
très forte équipe
les américains qui ont tous choqués
du mal à y croire parce que ça avait mal
commencé mais un peu comme contre les
bras ils sont remontées n'en vraiment un
super super match ils ont fait ils ont
mis les points où il le fallait et c'est
vrai que caruana coûte cher à son équipe
un il coûte très cher à son équipe
en tout cas c'est simple
c'est plus sympa que le format des
pcistes despitch est ce parce que sa
garde un peu plus de tension jusqu'à la
fin quand les matches sont serrés il ya
plus de matches serrés en pro de chasse
league même si on n'a pas eu de chance
avec les demi-finales et le match pour
la troisième place
on est un peu plus de matière et donc je
vais être une petite pub et puis je vais
vous laisser demain je vous rappelle
qu'on a le le court avec vatin lecourbe
là qui montrera ses plus belles parties
enfants sera marrant on a un style
différent et moi je suivre aussi le
début du match de parham du coup mais
pas en entier
j'espère que ça vous a plu et on se
retrouve on se retrouve du coup de main
je mets la petite pub et mac val d'adour
à 20h30
mais n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur
twitter pour avoir les horaires le matin
twitter.com slash blitz le 8 et u stream
ça me permet de vous mettre les horaires
avant que ça parte tout cas merci
d'avoir suivi et on se retrouve on se
retrouve demain merci à tous chacha à
demain